Liebe Mitbürger, ich möchte Ihnen die organisierte Kriminalität der zweiten Generation heute vorstellen. Wer ab heute, dem 1. November 2007, einen neuen Pass beantragt, wird ausgeliefert werden können. Elektronische Pässe mit einem digitalen Foto im Chip werden Bedrohungen für diese Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 95. Mein Name ist wie immer Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer weiteren Iteration dieses kleinen Audiomagazins, was auf verlorenen Pfaden durch das Internet tingelt und hier und da wieder runtergeladen wird. Und man bekommt aber doch von Zeit zu Zeit immer wieder sinnbringendes Feedback. Da kann ich mich bei euch eigentlich nur bedanken und das mache ich vielleicht hier auch an dieser Stelle mal, weil ich doch sehr viel zurückgespürt bekomme von den Leuten, die Chaosradio Express hören und die von euch, die vielleicht schon immer mal drüber nachgedacht haben, das zu tun, aber es noch nicht getan haben, kann ich nur ermutigen, meldet euch, sagt, was euch gefällt, was euch nicht gefällt. Das hilft doch sehr, dieses Format hier weiterzuentwickeln und weiterentwickelt werden soll es. Chaosradio Express wird dieses Jahr weitersenden und derzeit ist gerade mal wieder auch eine Phase erhöhter Nachrichtendichte und auch Sendungsdichte, was ganz gut ist. Da gab es jetzt eine Phase mit viel Technik und jetzt die Livesendung auch im Rahmen der Funkwelle FM, dieses kleinen UKW-Projekt hier in Berlin, hat ein paar Sendungsthemen hervorgebracht, die sich auch mehr mit der gesellschaftlichen Seite oder sagen wir mal dem kulturellen Bereich auch auseinandersetzen und nicht so hardcore Technikthemen sind. Aber was ein bisschen gefehlt hat, ist die nackte Politik und da wollen wir dann heute mal nachlegen. Und Schwerpunktmäßig soll es gehen um Netzpolitik im Allgemeinen und das Telekom-Paket im Besonderen. Na ja, und wer sollte sich zur Netzpolitik kompetenter äußern als Markus Beckedahl? Hallo Markus.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, wir haben gerade mal nachgeblättert. Du warst ja schon mal hier im Programm. Allerdings war das Ausgabe Nummer 7. Meine Güte, ist das lange her. Wir haben schon länger jetzt mal darüber gesprochen, mal wieder eine neue Sendung zu machen, weil sich eigentlich so viel aufstaut. Gerade das letzte Jahr war ja voll mit Themen, Vorratsdatenspeicherung war natürlich so ein bisschen das alles überschattende Über-Thema, aber Überwachungsthemen aller Art. Ich weiß nicht, was würdest du so als die Top 10 des letzten Jahres reflektieren, was dich auch permanent vor das Mikrofon getrieben hat?
Ja, Vorratsdatenspeicherung war auf jeden Fall das Top-Thema. Die Online-Durchsuchung ist ja ein Running-Gag, der eigentlich auch immer noch nicht so wirklich beendet ist. Biometrische Pässe waren auf jeden Fall ein Thema. Die Urheberrechtsdebatte, die geht ja immer weiter. Man denkt, jetzt ist das Ende endlich erreicht und es wird immer extremer. Ja, sonst, es gibt ja noch ein paar Positivthemen, wie Creative Commons, wie die Entwicklung von freier Software, wie Wikipedia, also die ganzen schönen Beispiele einer Digitalkultur und Blogs, soziale Medien, was da alles Neues entsteht. Das ist ein kultureller Medienwandel, der im vollen Gang ist und der tolle Blüten hervorbringt. Und das kann man dann immer entgegensetzen. Also die Welt ist nicht nur schlecht, sondern ja, es ist einfach so ein Strukturwandel.
Trotzdem ist Aktivismus angesagt. Was die positiven Themen betrifft, bisher war ich in letzter Zeit wieder sehr fleißig gewesen, auch auf deinem eigenen Podcast-Kanal, also auf netzpolitik.org. Das Blog werden sicherlich sowieso die meisten Leute kennen, die das hören, die es nicht kennen. Kann man sagen, Netzpolitik ist eigentlich doch das meistgelesenste Blog, was so eben genau diese ganzen Themen, die du gerade angesprochen hast und noch viel mehr darüber hinaus zusammenfasst und sich engagiert und sich einmischt, was ich besonders interessant finde. Das Einmischen war ja hier auch vor einiger Zeit ein Thema. Ich habe mit dem Falk Lücke eine Sendung gemacht, Politik für Einsteiger, Anfänger, was gar nicht wie ich es genannt habe, um einfach mal so einen Einblick zu kriegen, wie das politische System, am Beispiel der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, so funktioniert. Und um auch mal ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie man sich einbringen kann. Ein paar Thesen davon waren zum Beispiel die dringende Empfehlung, sich möglichst auch mal direkt an diese Leute zu wenden und sie jetzt nicht unbedingt immer nur ins Netz zu schimpfen, wie scheiße alles ist, sondern die Leute einfach mal anzurufen oder vorbeigehen in ihren Büros. Du hast ja jetzt so einen besonderen Fokus eigentlich mit der Netzpolitik. Auch ein Begriff, den du selber geprägt hast, kann man sagen. Was von dem, was Falk damals ausgeführt hat, kannst du denn da auch für deine Arbeit in Anspruch nehmen? Oder anders gefragt, was ist denn so dein Blickwinkel, wie man denn wirklich Einfluss nehmen kann und sollte?
Das ist natürlich eine komplexe Frage. Netzpolitik wird eigentlich auf allen Ebenen gemacht. Von der kommunalen Ebene bis hin zu den Vereinten Nationen. Da hat man die unterschiedlichsten Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten. Und auf den verschiedensten Ebenen werden einfach verschiedenste Entscheidungen getroffen, die unser Leben und die halt Gestaltung einer digitalen Gesellschaft beeinflussen. Auf kommunaler Ebene fängt das an mit Sachen wie, möchten wir jetzt ein kommunales WLAN haben? Einfach sehen wir als Internet als Zugang an. Sehen wir Internet eigentlich als Menschenrecht an, den Zugang zu Wissen, den Zugang zur Kommunikation? Und sehen wir es als öffentliche Daseinsfürsorge an? Das heißt, muss sich eigentlich eine Kommune darum kümmern, dass es einen Basiszugang zum Netz gibt oder nicht? Immerhin gibt es auch Straßen und Bürgersteige und all sowas. Da kümmert sich ja auch die Stadt oder die Kommune drum. Und die werden ja auch nicht privatisiert und von irgendwelchen Unternehmen gelegt.
Trotzdem muss man sich schon auch mittlerweile daran beteiligen, wenn dann mal die Straße zum eigenen Haus verlängert werden soll.
Ja klar, aber das sind halt so grundsätzliche Fragen. Möchte man halt, dass der Zugang zum Netz komplett privatisiert ist? Oder denkt man sich, naja, eigentlich könnte man halt schon annehmen, dass in einer digitalen Gesellschaft so ein Basiszugang zumindest gewährleistet werden sollte. Immerhin kann sich nicht jeder so einen fetten Internetzugang leisten. Außerdem wollen wir alle irgendwie Internet im Park haben. Das ist halt so was auf kommunaler Ebene. Betrifft weitere Themen, die vielleicht auf kommunaler Ebene passen, sind halt E-Partizipation. Gibt es irgendwelche Bürgerbeteiligungsprojekte, die das Internet einsetzen? Immerhin bietet das Internet eine ganze Menge mehr Möglichkeiten zur Partizipation auf kommunaler Ebene, wo die Menschen direkt beteiligt sind. Aber Politik funktioniert auf kommunaler Ebene vor allem dadurch, dass man in einer Fraktion mitarbeitet oder zu Ausschusssitzungen hingeht. Die sind meistens zeitlich und örtlich ein bisschen limitiert. Das heißt, man muss um 17 Uhr irgendwo in einer Ausschusssitzung sein, um da mal zuzuhören, vielleicht auch mal den Mund aufmachen zu können. Oder nutzt man das Internet als Medium, diese überschaubaren Prozesse einfach mal, orts- und zeitunabhängig, mit allen Beteiligten oder zumindest die Möglichkeit zu geben, dass alle Beteiligten, nämlich die Anwohner vor Ort, da mitdiskutieren können.
Und was sind denn deine Antworten auf diese Fragen? Ist denn jetzt so etwas wie ein kommunales WLAN wirklich, glaubst du, dass das funktionieren würde?
Wenn man sich anschaut, wie weltweit in verschiedensten Städten Großprojekte präsentiert worden sind, wo irgendwelche Unternehmen quasi ein Monopol bekommen haben, um eine WLAN-Ausstattung in diesen Kommunen zu betreiben, dann sieht man, dass gerade die Städte, die alles komplett privatisiert haben, in der Regel gescheitert sind. Dann haben die Unternehmen festgestellt, in der Aufbauphase oder kurz danach, das rentitiert sich alles gar nicht, und dann haben sie es wieder eingestampft. Es gibt Kommunen, die das als eigene Daseinsvorsorge begriffen haben.
Das ist noch mal ein Beispiel. Ich kenne jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nur die gescheiterten Projekte.
Das Problem in Deutschland fällt mir nur Heidelberg ein, wo das halt so einer halböffentlichen, halb privaten Trägerschaft die Innenstadt vernetzt werden soll. Ich weiß nicht, wie weit das Projekt ist. Das war aber das einzige Leuchtturmprojekt, das wir in Deutschland haben. In Österreich gibt es und in der Schweiz gibt es teilweise recht offene, freie Kooperationen. Innsbruck ist es glaube ich ein Beispiel. Ich muss hier noch mal genauer nachschauen. Und andere Städte. Es gibt aber in den USA ein grandios gescheitertes, in San Francisco ein grandioses gescheitertes.
In Berlin war glaube ich auch mal in der Diskussion.
Genau. Die ganzen großen Projekte, die wir in den Online-Medien waren, sind alle gescheitert. Aber es gibt viele kleine Projekte von Städten, die man jetzt gar nicht so genau kennt, aber wo das tatsächlich irgendwie funktioniert. Ein langsamer Aufbau, aber jetzt nicht so dieses große Bramborium. Und es geht ja auch erstmal darum, irgendwie zu sagen, man macht sich darüber Gedanken und eine digitale Gesellschaft, das jetzt zusammen entsteht. Und einfach mal, bevor wir vor vollendeten Tatsachen stehen, einfach mal zu sagen, darüber muss jetzt einfach mal nachgedacht werden, bevor das alles privatisiert ist, bevor das alles zu spät ist und keine andere Möglichkeit mehr da ist. Die Politik muss eigentlich auch erstmal den Willen zeigen, dass man sich zu solchen Sachen Gedanken macht. Wenn man sich jetzt mal hier Berlin anschaut, Berlin hat eine rege Freifunk-Community. Die bauen sich ihre eigenen Infrastrukturen auf. Das funktioniert in bestimmten Bereichen so ein bisschen leidlich. Manchmal funktioniert das gut. Aber die Stadt geht halt hin und plant die ganze Zeit, jetzt an irgendein großes Unternehmen quasi das Monopol zu vergeben, hier eine ganze Infrastruktur aufzubauen. Das Ganze ist dann halt nicht mit so einem Basiszugang verbunden. Es gäbe so einfache Sachen erst mal so, dass die Stadt den Willen erklärt hat. Die Freifunk-Community hat öfter schon angeboten, wir können euch da helfen und beraten. Also es ist anzunehmen, dass in dieser ganzen Behörde keiner genau weiß, was sie da machen und sich halt quasi so irgendein großes Unternehmen ausliefern, die dann quasi das Monopol bekommen.
Aber kommen wir nicht genau an der Stelle auch wirklich an so ein grundsätzliches Problem, nämlich das Problem der Organisationsform. Also als große Firma mit einer starken Lobby, was weiß ich, vielleicht noch so ein Branchenverband mit im Nacken, da wissen wir, die kommen irgendwie weit und eigentlich überall hin. Sowas wie die Freifunk-Community, um das mal als Beispiel rauszugreifen, ist ein loses Rodel von Aktivisten, die ja schwierig mit einer Stimme sprechen können und wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt vorhaben, immer mit einer Stimme zu sprechen. Inwiefern kann denn so eine Organisationsform da auch erfolgreich sein?
Also eine Organisationsform wie die Freifunk-Community ist ja ähnlich aufgebaut wie eigentlich so die Open-Source-Welt. Also da gibt es einen Haufen Freiwilliger und die basteln so vor sich hin und irgendwie funktioniert das Ganze so dezentral und man baut dann, die einen bauen Antennen, die anderen bauen sie wiederum auf, die dritten entgegeln die Firmware und das setzt sich dann alles so dezentral zu so einem Netz zusammen. Zum Beispiel gegenüber der Politik hatten wir ja halt über einen Abgeordneten hier im Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus mal eine Anfrage gestellt, ob sich die Politik mal Gedanken gemacht hat, wie man so diese Kultur fördern kann. Immerhin schafft es die Freifunk-Community, über 500 Hotspots hier in Berlin zu errichten, auch schon einige kulturelle Städte ans Netz anzuschließen. Und das ist doch ein zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement, wie es im Buchel steht. Wenn man sich halt mal Politikerreden anhört, die wünschen sich doch eigentlich sowas.
Ja, aber wen rufen die dann an? Ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, dass so der technisch auch in der Regel wahrscheinlich nicht so versierte Entscheidungsträger einfach ein Problem hat mit dieser Organisationsform, dass er nicht morgens um 9 anrufen kann und dass sie kein Büro hat und vielleicht auch kein Faxgerät.
Das mag ein Problem sein, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sich überhaupt jemand schon mal Gedanken gemacht hat, irgendwie die anzurufen, weil dann hätte man einfach eine Mail an Info at Freifunk oder was weiß ich, was auf der Webseite steht, schicken müssen. Sowas ist ja noch niemals, was passiert. Und halt in dieser Anfrage, die halt diese Abgeordnete an die Verwaltung gestellt hat, kam also die Antwort zurück, ja, finden wir alles toll, müssen wir nicht fördern, läuft ja alles ganz gut und es war explizit halt in dieser Anfrage auch drin, dürfen die dann auf Dächer drauf. Weil du kannst schön deine Antenne in der Seabase bauen und so weiter, du kannst auch schön die Firmware und so weiter haben, meistens scheitert dieses zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement daran, dass man auf so ein Dach drauf muss, um einfach mal so eine schöne Richtfunkantenne anzuschließen, die man selbst finanziert, dann vielleicht scheitert es manchmal noch dran, wenn man irgendwie eine Kirche gefunden hat, mit dem Fahrgemeinderat wochenlang irgendwie verhandelt hat in seiner Freizeit, wo man auch bessere Sachen hätten machen können, an der Frage, wir zeiten jetzt den Strom für den Router. Das sind so einfache Sachen. Da könnte eigentlich so eine Gemeindeverwaltung sagen, wir finden das toll, wir fördern das. Wir können ja immer noch parallel unser eigenes großes Netz aufbauen mit irgendeiner Firma, wo die Consultants mit bunten PowerPoint-Präsentationen ankommen. Aber wir fördern das parallel und erlauben, dass diese Antennen auf unseren öffentlichen Gebäuden aufgestellt werden können. Aber da ist halt gar kein Wille da. Und das ist halt das Traurige. Aber lustigerweise hat diese Freifunk-Anfrage irgendwie gebracht. Das ist halt lauter. Da war halt auch eine Frage drin, wo dürfen die denn schon auf Dächern? Das ging halt runter in sämtliche, also wenn ein Abgeordneter eine Anfrage stellt, dann muss das halt überall überprüft werden. Und dann ging halt diese Anfrage in lauter Verwaltungsgebäude und sonstige rein. Und das führte dazu, dass sich dezentral wiederum irgendwelche Leute von den untersten kommunalen Ebenen an die Freifunker banden und halt Bereitschaft signalisierten auf unsere Däche. Könnt ihr drauf.
Du hast vorhin auch jetzt neben diesem WLAN-Beispiel, das war jetzt schon etwas konkret, aber ich liebe konkrete Beispiele, auch so die Idee der e-Participation eingebracht. Was schwebt dir denn da konkret vor? Also die Frage war, wollen wir e-Participation haben? Was ist denn so die Antwort?
Ja, ganz klar wollen wir die haben. Also e-Participation, früher hat man das e-Demokratie genannt, ist eigentlich so eine Diskussion, die gibt es seit 10 Jahren. Zumindest verfolge ich sie seit 10 Jahren. Und da kann man halt sagen, die Diskussion geht einfach nicht weiter, weil der politische Wille fehlt einfach. Es gibt ein paar sehr schöne Projekte aus Deutschland, aber die sind immer noch Leuchtturmprojekte. Immer noch 10 Jahre später, also zum Beispiel hier in Berlin, in Lichtenberg, da wurde der Bürgerhaushalt offen diskutiert. Also so eine Kommune oder eine kommunale Ebene, Lichtenberg ist ein Bezirk wiederum, vergleichbar vielleicht mit einem Kreis irgendwo anders außerhalb einer Großstadt. Die hat da halt einen Haushalt. Und so ein Haushalt bestimmt halt, wo geht das Geld hin. Normalerweise gibt es halt dann im Haushaltsausschuss auf so einer kommunalen Ebene, streiten sich dann, gehen wir jetzt irgendwie 100.000 Euro mehr aus für irgendwie einen Radweg oder kaufen wir dafür lieber irgendwie Kitas oder sonst irgendwie. Und da ist halt dieser Haushalt offen diskutiert worden. Und da kann man halt viel mehr irgendwie, zumindest erstmal die Bürger ihre Wünsche artikulieren lassen. Man hat auch oftmals die Situation, dass halt Bürger...
In welcher Form?
In welcher Form. Also meistens findet das leider immer noch in Form von Foren statt. Foren sind so irgendwie so ein Medium, was ich vor zig Jahren schon langweilig fand. Aber immerhin besser als nichts. Und es gibt dann noch eine ganze Menge Leute, die halt noch nicht so internetne Nettafin sind wie wir. Und die halt erstmal toll finden, halt orts- und zeitabhängig ihre Meinung zu einem Thema Kunst zu tun. Es gibt andere Beispiele. Früher hat man dann irgendwie eher runde Tische oder sonstige Konzepte gemacht. Da hat man dann die Bürger an einen Tisch geholt, um halt mal zu diskutieren, wie wollen wir jetzt unseren neuen Marktplatz gestalten? Was gibt es da für Ideen? Ganz früher hat man einfach irgendwie der Bürgermeister entschieden, da kommt eine große Statue hin oder sonst irgendwie, und dann geht jetzt so und so viel Geld rein. Aber die Bürger selbst irgendwie ihre Umgebung mitbestimmen zu lassen, ist erstmal ein tolles Beispiel. Dann gibt es andere...
Ja, aber wie funktioniert das in I? Ich meine, ich denke, wir teilen da auch eine gewisse Grunderfahrung mit elektronischen Medien, dass eine wirkliche Entscheidungsfindung oder auch nur eine Diskussion über ein Thema sehr schwierig ist. Also es gibt einfach relativ wenig Kommunikationsformen jetzt im Netz insbesondere, wo es wirklich leicht ist, einen Fortschritt herauszulesen. Einen Fortschritt in der Meinungsbildung und so weiter. Man kommt dann immer schnell... Also gerade so diese Anfänge dieser ganzen E-Participation gingen ja dann auch schnell in dieses Na ja, wir stimmen dann halt ab. Wo wir dann sofort wieder im E-Voting- und Wahlcomputersumpf sind, wo wir denke ich eigentlich sind, dass das nicht der Weg sein kann, weil man dann einfach Entscheidungen elektronischen Systemen überlässt oder zumindest auf ihrer Sicherheit aufbaut, die einfach nicht gewährleistet werden kann. Also Abstimmung kann es nicht sein. Eine offene Diskussion ist aber etwas, was eben schnell zerfasert. Wir haben auch Mailinglisten, wir kennen alle diese Flame Wars-Foren. Ich teile da deine Einschätzung, dass das einfach suboptimale Systeme sind, weil man dem Gesprächsfluss schlecht folgen kann. Und vor allem, wie macht man sich halt bemerkbar? Wie bringt man vor allem auch seine eigene Person da mit ins Spiel über so einen kleinen lustigen Avatar hinaus? Also ich habe wirklich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass es ein Werkzeug gibt im i-Bereich, das funktionieren kann.
Also das ist natürlich genauso wie im normalen Leben. Pack mal alle interessierten Bürger an einem Thema, irgendwie samstags nachmittags in die Stadthalle und lass die einfach irgendwie miteinander diskutieren. Wenn du keine Moderation dabei hast, die das Ganze in die richtige Richtung lenkt, dann hast du Chaos. Dann brüllen die sich alle nieder und zum Schluss ist halt irgendwie der lauteste und größte, quasi, hat sich durchgesetzt. Das ist keine Lösung. Also auch wenn man halt irgendwie in Form von Foren oder Blogs oder so weiter, was halt wie gesagt noch nicht so wirklich ausprobiert wurde, wir reden da von Leuchtturmprojekten in Deutschland, wenn man halt davon ausgeht, dann brauchst du halt so eine Moderation, dann muss halt auch ausgehen, da beteiligt sich einfach nicht jeder dran. Also es ist ja auch immer die Angst so, oh Gott, wir leben in einer 40.000 Einwohner-Stadt, und wenn jetzt 40.000 Leute diskutieren, dann haben wir ein Problem. Aber es geht ja darum, bisher diskutieren dann in so einer 40.000 Einwohner-Stadt, diskutieren vielleicht 20, 30 Leute in den Ausschüssen im Kommunalparlament.
Das interessiert es ja auch nicht mehr.
Ja, nee, nee, also es interessiert schon mehr. Aber wenn du halt von diesen 40.000 nur irgendwie 200 oder 500 Menschen dazu bekommst, dann ist das schon viel, also das ist schon viel mehr, als sich jetzt an der Demokratie beteiligen.
Gut, aber mir fehlt immer noch so ein bisschen der konkrete Vorschlag, was für Mittel das sind. Ist das sozusagen, dass man dann die Ausschüsse erstmal ins Internet streamt? Wäre das schon mal ein Anfang?
Also es ist generell eine Möglichkeit, einfach mal Politik transparent zu machen. Sichtbar zu machen.
Also eigentlich nicht transparent zu machen.
Also transparent quasi für die interessierten Bürger, die einer politischen Debatte folgen wollen. Früher hatten wir die Situation, okay, dann ist da irgendwie was diskutiert worden. Man hatte sein lokales Käseblatt, was dann auch irgendwie über die Ergebnisse berichtete. Und dann haben sich dann alle bei der Fraktion und den meisten immer aufgeregt, dass sie da nicht so wirklich irgendwie vorgekommen sind, sondern nur meistens irgendwie die führende CDU oder SPD oder wer da gerade irgendwie an der Macht war. Aber jetzt haben wir eigentlich die Möglichkeit, so quasi erstmal Informationen zu liefern. Man kann auch irgendwie so Ausschusssitzungen einfach mal aufzeichnen. Und wenn es nun schlechter Qualität ist, dass jemand seinen MP3-Recorder dahinstellt, aber wenn man das dann mal ins Netz stellt, was ja, wir machen das ja täglich, das ist ja nicht mehr das Problem, hätte ich eigentlich als, sagen wir mal, ich bin eine Mutter, hüte mein Kind, aber kann ich zu diesen Ausschusssitzungen hin, aber mich betrifft jetzt irgendein Thema auf kommunaler Ebene. Ja, wieso kann ich mir das denn nicht irgendwie anhören? Ich muss da ganz lange warten, bis irgendwelche Protokolle da sind, wenn es so ein Protokolle gibt oder sonst wie, vielleicht gibt es ja auf der Internetseite...
Also Ausschusssitzungen als Podcasts?
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht die Lösung aller Dinge, aber das ist eine Grundvoraussetzung.
Ich will nur mal von der Theorie weg, wirklich mal so ein paar praktische Sachen, weil an der Praxis scheitert es ja meist. Wir haben alle möglichen Initiativen gesehen, wo sich große Entitäten den Staat eingeschlossen, so mit Deutschland jetzt im Internet. Dann haben sie halt tolle Webseiten gehabt, da irgendwie ein Flash-Klimb drauf gemacht, keiner kam damit klar.
Das waren aber Einwege, Kommunikationswege.
Ja gut, aber man könnte auch sagen, das waren auch Experimente, um zu schauen, was man macht. Da sind sie vielleicht schlecht beraten worden. Ich frag mich jetzt wirklich, und wir wollen ja hier auch ein bisschen versuchen, was Verwertbares für den interessierten Aktivisten zu machen, was kann man konkret tun, was vielleicht auch sinnvoll ist und was auch funktioniert? Du hast jetzt mehrfach schon die kommunale Ebene insbesondere ins Feld gehoben.
Das war einfach nur das vor der Anfang, um mal von den Ebenen irgendwie...
Ja, aber vielleicht ist das ja auch wirklich der effizienteste Bereich.
Ja, also wenn man Netzpolitik machen möchte, jetzt nicht unbedingt, aber es ist der effizienteste Bereich, wenn man mit Politik anfangen möchte, wenn man halt an einer Demokratie richtig aktiv teilhaben möchte, wo man auch irgendwie relativ schnell was erreichen kann. Weil es sind relativ wenige involvierte Entscheidungsprozesse, weil es ist direkt etwas, was vor meiner Haustür quasi passiert. Das ist in vielen Fällen etwas, was sofort mein Leben beeinflusst.
Und es ist nicht so aufgeladen durch die Medienberichterstattung, die ja sich immer sehr auf Bundes-
und Landesthemen konzentriert. Genau, und wenn man sich halt auch mal mit Kommunalpolitik innerhalb von Parteien oder Fraktionen beschäftigt hat, dann kann man das eigentlich, dieses Wissen, was man da gesammelt hat, auf alle politischen Ebenen auch übertragen. Weil Politik funktioniert auf allen Ebenen genauso. Es sind einfach Menschen, die irgendwie um Macht ringen und Sachen durchbringen wollen. Und wenn man mal im Ortsvorstand von einer Partei oder sonst irgendwie war, dann kann man es auch auf dem Bundesvorstand der Partei die selben sozialen Prozesse irgendwie ausdehnen. Weil das sind genauso Menschen, die genauso Politik machen und Mehrheiten organisieren wollen und so weiter. Also insofern ist es eigentlich ein sehr nettes Spielfeld. Leider am meisten oder was heißt, viele Leute fangen erst an, sich mit Kommunalpolitik zu beschäftigen, wenn sie Kinder in die Welt setzen und denken, sie müssen jetzt mal die nähere Umgebung für ihre Kinder schöner machen.
Das stimmt wohl.
Du hast ja auch schon mal überlegt, neue Bürgersteige und mehr Kinder.
Na ja, wenn man Kinder hat und so, da kommen halt so was wie Kindertagesstätten und so weiter. Klar, da blickt man natürlich ganz anders auf die Welt. So hat so jeder immer so seinen Themensperrpunkt. Klar, in der aufgeklärten Digitalszene ist es sicherlich dann auch eher das, was auf Landesebene und auf Bundesebene abläuft, was für einen jetzt erst mal relevant ist. Du bist ja jetzt im Prinzip gleich kommunal eingestiegen auf das Thema jetzt mit diesem Beispiel des WLANs. Ich frage mich jetzt auch immer noch, und da würde ich auch ganz gerne nochmal nachbeißen, was du für funktionierende Diskussionsmedien hältst. Also welche Systeme bringen deiner Auffassung und Erfahrung nach auch wirklich einen politischen Diskurs ins Spiel, in dem man übers Internet teilnehmen kann, wo auch was passiert?
Wikis? Erstmal Wikis, ja Wikis weiß ich noch nicht. Einfach die Menschen, die normalerweise Politik aktiv machen, in irgendwelchen Funktionen. Das ist ja den vollkommen fremd, dass man irgendwie ein Wiki nutzt und so weiter. Du kannst mit Wikis eine ganze Menge Sachen machen. Man sollte auch da immer nicht vergessen, egal was man irgendwie an Partizipationswerkzeugen hat. Man braucht eine Moderation, man braucht eine erfahrene Moderation. Auch die Wikipedia funktioniert nicht ohne Moderatorin. Also Administratoren, die das Ganze nochmal in die richtige Richtung lenken können. Jetzt, es geht ja erstmal darum, dass man den Willen hat, einfach diese elektronischen oder digitalen Medien auszuprobieren. Ich weiß auch noch nicht, was jetzt irgendwie das perfekte Ding ist, aber das liegt halt daran, dass ja, es ist eigentlich noch nichts wirklich passiert worden. Vielleicht brauchen wir da auch noch Tools oder eine Kombination an Tools irgendwie. Vielleicht brauchen wir da auch einfach noch mehr Experimentierfreude, um auszuprobieren, was geht und was geht nicht. Um zu dem perfekten System zu finden. Also ich weiß halt nur, es gibt eine ganze Menge kleine Beispiele. Zum Beispiel ein anderes Werkzeug ist halt, wo die Bürger quasi den Haushalt anhand von so Flasch-Schiebereglern irgendwie dirigieren können. Wo du halt sagst, du hast eine Million Haushalt und musst das mal aufteilen auf Radwege, auf Autobahnen ausbauen, auf Kitas und so weiter. Und alle fordern immer mehr Kitas, mehr Radwege und sonst wie. Wenn du mal auf so einem kleinen Tool sitzt und dann mal hin und her schiebst, dann stellst du halt fest, wenn du mehr Kitas willst, dann musst du aber einen Radwegen sparen und sonst irgendwie. Du stellst halt fest, dass Geld nicht endlich ist. Aber das führt halt zu einem kleinen Lernprozess. Das führt halt dazu, dass man...
So ist das was Theoretisches oder was es tatsächlich gab?
Das ist tatsächlich irgendwie so ein kleines Tool. Das entwickelt so eine kleine universitäre Firma aus Hamburg.
Was war jetzt auch ein Name, URL, sonst irgendwas?
Das ist die Firma TU-Tech. Das habe ich mir mal angeschaut. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Unternehmen, welche Kommunen das einsetzen, aber das war halt, ja, das habe ich sofort verstanden, okay, dass es was sehr Sinnvolles ist.
Stimmt, das ist eine interessante Idee. Im Prinzip ist es so dieses spielerische, ja, dass man sozusagen, eine Simulation des tatsächlichen Prozesses anhand realer Daten, dass man sozusagen, wir machen, was wäre, wenn ich jetzt Bürgermeister bin? Und dann, dass man sozusagen, das heißt, die Realität wird dann in so ein Ultima Online irgendwie... Ich baue eine Turnhalle und so...
Genau, stell dir mal so ein Tool vor und befrag einfach mal irgendwie 1000 oder 5000 Leute und dann kriegst du halt einfach erstmal irgendwie so Zahlen raus und kriegst halt raus, wenn 5000 Leute wollen, 4000 mehr Kitas und sonst irgendwie. Dann weißt du halt, na gut, der Bürgerwille ist da, wir müssen halt einfach mal mehr Kitas schaffen und sonst irgendwie. Das Ganze ist dann meistens auch noch so transparent aufbereitet, dass halt die Politik da noch nicht hingehen kann und sagen kann, wir machen jetzt was ganz anderes da, weil jeder kann das ja eigentlich sehen. Und das Problem an der Politik ist ja immer, dass halt die Entscheidungswege immer relativ intransparent nachvollziehbar sind. Und zum Schluss ist irgendein Ergebnis da und es wird dann halt an die Medien verkündet, ja, alles super und toll. Oder wir haben jetzt einen Kompromiss gemacht, aber alles super und toll. Aber ist es ja für einen Bürger, der eigentlich quasi nicht komplett so eine Debatte nachvollzieht, ist es ja nicht anhand von einem 15-Sekunden-Statement nachvollziehbar. Warum habt ihr das jetzt so entschieden?
Da fällt mir wieder die alte CCC-Forderung ein nach der maschinenlesbaren Regierung.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine Forderung, die ich immer irgendwie stelle. Wir brauchen offene Schnittstellen, auch bei der Bundesregierung. Generell bei den ganzen Verwaltungen brauchen wir offene Schnittstellen. Wir reden da alle davon, dass man technische offene Schnittstellen überall hat. Aber was ist denn... Was für Schnittstellen? Also das fängt ja ganz einfach an. Du hast immer versucht, bei bundestag.de Gesetzestexte runterzuladen oder Protokolle oder sonst irgendwie, um daraus sogenannte Mash-ups oder Transparenzprojekte zu machen in vielen anderen Ländern. Ich war zuletzt auf einer kleinen E-Domocracy-Konferenz. Da waren Transparenzprojekte aus allen möglichen Ländern.
Wo war die?
Die war hier in Berlin. Das war eher so ein Barcamp-mäßig. Man hat sich da in kleinen Gruppen irgendwie selbst organisiert. Aber das waren super Dinge. Ein Projekt aus Rumänien, das fand ich schon ein bisschen lustig. Die untersuchen anhand von, was auf den Seiten des EU-Parlament steht. Welche Abgeordnete waren jetzt eigentlich, wie oft überhaupt im Parlament drin? Und visualisieren das in Stellzeit West? Da gibt es ein paar Abgeordnete, die waren 2% aller Anwesenheitszeiten überhaupt erst da. Und da gibt es andere, die haben fast 100% erreicht. Parlament oder Ausschüsse?
Im Parlament.
Dann kriegst du erst mal so ein Gefühl dafür, da muss man eigentlich nicht noch mal wählen. Oder die Partei, wenn ihr halt...
Aber das ist immer so eine sehr populistische Geschichte mit dieser Parlamentsanwesenheit. Weil das ja eigentlich nicht wirklich so relevant ist.
Ja, da war dann auch eine aus Deutschland, Koch Merin von FDP, wenn man halt nicht weiß, dass sie gerade wieder mein Kind bekommen hat, dann denkt man halt, die ist total faul. Die war dann wahrscheinlich ein Jahr lang im Babyurlaub, aber die war am zweitbildigsten da.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch so, das Parlament ist ja nun wirklich die Abstimmung und ich meine, die Parlamentsdiskussion ist ja keine Ahnung, ob das überhaupt noch irgendwas bedeutet, aber was ich halt auch selbst festgestellt habe, es war jetzt ein Podcast mit Falk auch da, ich hab jetzt auch selber mal ein bisschen Ausschüsse besucht seitdem, so das ist ja eigentlich der Ort, wo wirklich die Politik gemacht wird.
Genau.
Und ja, aber die Idee mit den Schnittstellen finde ich gerade sehr gut, aber ich kann noch ein paar mehr Beispiele, wenn da noch so interessante Sachen gekommen sind.
In den USA gibt es eine beeindruckende Organisation, Sunlight Foundation. Habe ich auch zuletzt einen Podcast von einem Entwickler gemacht. Sunlight Foundation gibt es erst seit 2 oder 3 Jahren, wird mittlerweile gefördert von Google und verschiedenen anderen größeren Unternehmen. Die haben also echt fett Geld und können 40 Leute irgendwie beschäftigen, die meisten davon Entwickler und die machen nichts anderes als kleine Mash-ups wie, naja, wir legen jetzt mal die US-Spenden-Datenbanken, also welche Unternehmen oder Menschen haben an die Politiker gespendet, die sind ja offen transparent einsehbar, die legen wir damit übereinander mit den Informationen aus anderen Datenbanken, wofür haben die Politiker gestimmt. Und dann kann man eigentlich irgendwie schön das Ganze visualisiert darstellen und halt irgendwie Geldflüsse und Entscheidungsflüsse irgendwie für die Bürger transparent darstellen und dann kann man sich halt mal Gedanken machen, so entscheiden jetzt diese Politiker, die in ihren ganzen Wahlkampfspot immer sagen, wir kämpfen um sie und ihre Familien und kann man halt mal schauen, naja, eigentlich kämpfen die eigentlich nur für die Ölindustrie und für die Pharmaindustrie. Also das sind so nette Tools. In den USA ist das alles möglich, weil sämtliche öffentliche Informationen stehen unter der Public Domain. Das heißt, sie sind gemeinfrei. In Deutschland, unser Gesetz des Texte alles, ist urheberrechtlich geschützt. Also wahrscheinlich sagt keiner was, wenn man irgendwie jetzt mal anfängt, irgendwie die Seiten des, die Protokolle der Ausschusssitzung mit irgendwie anderen öffentlichen Daten übereinanderzulegen. Aber man befindet sich auch immer in so einer Grauzone. Und es wäre auch viel cooler, wenn der Bundestag seine ganzen Daten in XML vorliegen hätte, dass man halt einfach viel besser irgendwie in guten Formaten diese ganzen Dateien, Daten einfach mal runterziehen könnte und halt mit anderen Datenbeständen einfach...
Also Daten, so wie... Was für Termine stehen an, aber natürlich dann auch konkret, was für Gesetze sind beschlossen worden, dass jede Paragrafenreferenz sozusagen auch wirklich als Link nachvollziehbar ist.
Also auf Bundesebene ist das Ganze jetzt... Also nicht so spannend wie auf EU-Ebene, weil wir haben auf Bundesebene den Fraktionszwang. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich in der Regel so, dass jeder FDP-Abgeordnete mit der ganzen FDP-Fraktion stimmt und alle anderen Fraktionen genauso. Im EU-Parlament ist es wiederum viel spannender. Im EU-Parlament hat man eigentlich wechselnde Mehrheiten. Das heißt, da ist dieser Fraktionszwang eigentlich gar nicht so da, sondern da sitzen 25 oder 27 Länder mittlerweile, also Abgeordnete aus den unterschiedlichen Ländern. Da gibt es zwar auch Fraktionen, aber das sind eigentlich eher so Fraktionen, die teilen sich gemeinsam, die Kopierer und so weiter. Weil wenn du einen Fraktionsstatus hast oder eine bestimmte Größe erreicht hast an einer Koalition, also einem Zusammenschluss von Abgeordneten aus unterschiedlichen Ländern, dann kriegst du halt Kopierer und Räume und sonstige Sachen. Aber da ist es halt viel spannender zu schauen, welche Abgeordneten haben wie gestimmt, wenn die Hälfte der SPD-Fraktion irgendwie für Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist und die andere dagegen, dann ist ja spannend zu sehen, wer hat denn jetzt dagegen entschieden oder wer, welcher EU-Abgeordnete stimmt denn jetzt für eine freie digitale Gesellschaft und wer ist eher irgendwie komplett auf Seiten der Musikindustrie. Also das kann man ja eigentlich aus den ganzen Daten rausziehen, aber im Moment ist es halt eher so eine total schwierige Arbeit, dass man halt sich durch die ganzen Protokolle wühlen muss.
Da wissen wir jetzt aber auch, warum es das nicht gibt. Ich meine, wenn die dann alle so nachvollziehbar werden.
Nee, die Verschwörungstheorien sehe ich da nicht. Das ist halt meistens technischer Unverstand. Irgendwie dann wird ihnen dann ein Content-Management verkauft, was sowas gar nicht kann. Da ist auch gar nicht der politische Erkenntnis da, dass sowas toll wäre, um eigentlich eine Demokratie zu beleben. Also das ist eigentlich eher Unwissenheit.
Ja, dann drehen wir das jetzt mal wieder zurück, um jetzt hier auch mal wieder ein paar konkrete Empfehlungen vielleicht oder Anregungen zumindest zu geben. Wenn man jetzt zu seiner Gemeinde geht, die ja beliebig klein sein kann, und sagt, okay, ihr habt irgendwie eine überschaubare Anzahl von Prozessen, da gibt es irgendwie mal ein paar Sitzungen die Woche, dann wird auch ab und zu mal wieder was beschlossen. Jetzt kümmern wir uns darum, das einfach mal zu digitalisieren und machen mal so ganz exemplarisch ein Digital Outlet der Gemeinde. Und dann liegt sozusagen alles auf einem Server rum und die Leute können sich das einfach schnappen und dann eben ihre Spezial-Webseiten bauen, um daraus Infosystem zu machen. Sowas schwebt dir vor?
Ähm, wäre doch nett. Ja, also da gibt es auch irgendwie...
Ich meine, es wäre doch zumindest etwas, wo man dann auch konkret sagen kann, sag uns nicht, dass das nicht geht. Wir haben das hier irgendwie mit zwei Leuten als Hobbyprojekt mal eben in drei Wochen gemacht. Warum tragen wir das jetzt nicht auf eine Bezirksebene, Landkreisebene, tra la la Landesebene, Bundeshebene?
Genau, also es gibt ja in vielen Kommunen, gibt es echt Menschen, die nehmen mit Hilfe eines Webblogs irgendwie die Lokalpolitik auf, so wie ich irgendwie auf netzpolitik.org alles rund um Netzpolitik aggregiere. Gibt es halt echt überall Leute, die halt einfach irgendwie alle Zeitungsartikel zu Entscheidungen im Parlament oder irgendwie Ausschusssitzungen einfach mal zusammen aggregieren, zusammenstellen, an einem Ort irgendwie lesbar aufbereiten. Das ist halt eine Form von zivilgesellschaftlichen Engagement, was vielleicht nicht gerade das Coolste und Tollste ist, womit man wahrscheinlich auch weniger Frauen aufreißen kann oder sonst wie, was ein bisschen mühselig ist, weil man muss es auch nachhaltig machen, aber es wäre konkret etwas, womit man erstmal mehr Transparenz schaffen würde. Eine andere Sache ist, im ganzen CCC-Umfeld gibt es eine ganze Menge sehr fitte Techies. Wieso schaut ihr nicht mal, was ihr mit öffentlichen Daten anfangen könnt? Genau, wieso schaut ihr euch nicht mal an? Solange die Maschinen-Despare-Regierung noch nicht da ist, man kann mit PerlScript eine ganze Menge von diesen Seiten trotzdem runterholen. Wieso schaut ihr euch nicht mal an, was Sunlight Foundation und andere coole Projekte machen? Und wieso macht ihr das nicht in Deutschland? Für einen Perlcoder braucht er nur ein paar Ideen. Und nur falls ihr keine Ideen habt, wir haben eine ganze Menge Ideen, was ihr machen könnt, spielt einfach mal mit eurer Technik rum und schaut, was ihr da irgendwie aus diesen ganzen Datenbergen irgendwie rausholen könnt.
Das Bundesmechanismus. Zum Beispiel. Gut, vielleicht jetzt mal so von diesen generellen Ausblicken und Wünschen. Meist ein bisschen weniger Netzpolitik, was wir besprochen haben, als mehr so konkrete Beteiligung und zur Hilfenahme digitaler Wege. Das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll. Was jetzt die netzpolitischen Vorgänge betrifft, wir haben es schon angesprochen, war das letzte Jahr sehr reich an Aktivität. Und wie du ja auch schon gesagt hast, Vorratsdatenspeicherung war natürlich das totale Metathema. Und ich denke, das war es vor allem auch deshalb wegen dieser ganz speziellen Gruppe, die sich dort gebildet hat, der AK Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Vielleicht kannst du ja mal, wenn du warst da ja relativ nah dran, was mich interessieren würde ist, was war, also ganz offensichtlich gab es ja wirklich eine Menge Mobilisierung. Also es war augenfällig, dass diese AK Vorratsdatenspeicherung sehr viel mehr Konkretes bewirkt hat in Form von rechtlichen Widerstand, Einspruch beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, organisieren, aber dann eben auch die ganzen Demonstrationen, die dann mit dazu kamen, plus der ganzen Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Öffentlichkeitsarbeit sind wir jetzt irgendwie gewohnt, auch gerade im Clubumfeld. Klar, der CCC schaut sich immer wieder Sachen an, die Medien greifen das auf, aber das sind dann natürlich auch immer nur so Lautbarungen. Wir wollen ja eigentlich weiterkommen, wir wollen ja auch sozusagen auch wirklich was ändern und nicht immer nur beklagen, dass alles so scheiße ist. Was hat jetzt an dieser AK Vorratsdatenspeicherung gut funktioniert? Was hat vielleicht nicht so gut funktioniert? Also welche Lehren kann man jetzt aus diesem Projekt ziehen? Und inwiefern sollten die Modelle für zukünftiges sein?
Also erstmal, eigentlich hat das ganze Entwicklungsmodell des AK Vorrats ein Vorbild. Und das ist die Kampagne gegen Softwarepatente, die auf europäischer Ebene ein bisschen früher bewirkt hat, dass Softwarepatente in der Form, wie sie gewünscht war, also als Richtlinie, gar nicht durchgekommen ist. Das war eigentlich das erste Mal, dass so quasi transeuropäisch Nerds und Geeks einfach sich vernetzt haben, die digitale Tools genutzt haben, um halt mal zu schauen, wie kann man jetzt irgendwie Politik debuggen, wie kann man Politik hacken und wie kann man dabei noch Spaß haben und halt irgendwie möglichst unsere Kommunikationsform nutzen.
Das stimmt, die waren auch sehr, jetzt wo du es sagst, ganz klar, die waren extrem präsent, vor allem auch auf vielen Nerdkonferenzen präsent und haben da einfach auch Konkretes gezeigt.
Genau, und das Entwicklungsmodell quasi ist ein sehr ähnliches wie der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ich vergleiche das eigentlich immer mit einem Open Source Projekt. Es ist nicht mehr diese klassische Top-Down-Kampagne, das heißt, früher hat man dann eine Kampagne irgendwie auf dem Reißbrett entwickelt und viele Organisationen machen das ja immer noch. Man holt sich eine Werbungentur, die designt einem eine ganze Kampagne und dann schickt man die Poster irgendwie raus. Jeder Wahlkampf läuft im Großen und Ganzen genauso.
Du bist Deutschland.
Oder du bist Deutschland, ja genau. Das war wahrscheinlich die Kampagne mit dem meisten Geld außerhalb von Wahlkampfen in so einem politischen Umfeld.
Wenn man vielleicht mal die Initiative neue soziale Marktwirtschaft rausnimmt, die scheint mir noch mehr Geld zu haben.
Ja, ich glaube, die waren ja tatsächlich auch noch ein bisschen daran beteiligt. Das war ja irgendwie ein ähnliches Umfeld. Auf jeden Fall, Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat sich ja eigentlich mal, ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, wann das war. Es gab einen Kongress 2005 oder so und da gab es dann mal ein Treffen. Wir müssen was gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung tun, weil wir haben das auf EU-Ebene schon nicht geschafft. Ich meine, das war ja ein Prozess, der lief ja schon lange. Hat halt nur keinen interessiert. Also ich weiß, das erste Mal war es irgendwie im Fernsehen, als die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in der EU beschlossen war. Da war es abends in der Tagesschau. Ja, jetzt haben wir ein Problem. Wo man sich ganzheit denkt so, ja hallo. Die Medien selbst sind auch richtig erst draufgesprungen, als zwei Wochen oder einen Monat bevor es im Bundestag irgendwie dann endgültig beschlossen wurde, wo auch schon alles so spät war, wo sie dann feststellen, oh wir haben auch ein Problem, die Pressefreiheit ist in Gefahr.
Das fand ich aber schon in Leistung. Ich glaube, ohne den Protest der AKA-Vorwärtsentsprechung wäre da wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal drüber berichtet worden.
Ja, vermutlich. Das haben ja diese ganzen Technologie-Themen oder wo irgendwie Technologie im Spiel ist, haben ja immer das Problem so. Wenn man sich auch irgendwie anschaut, wer konsumiert die sogenannten alten Medien? Das sehen wir bei Zeitungslesern und sonstigen Sachen halt immer. Die werden immer älter, die sterben irgendwann aus, die Jungen nehmen uns in das Internet so. Ich habe auch oft genug die Situation, wo ich mit Journalisten rede, und die wollen gerne was über Themen berichten. Einerseits gibt es halt die Journalisten, die mir dann erzählen für ihre Zeitung. Können wir jetzt mal ein anderes Wort für Server finden? Das versteht unsere Zielgruppe nicht, wo ich dann denke, wir haben 2007 oder 2008 und ihr könnt jetzt ruhig schon Server schreiben. Und andere sagen halt, ich habe nur drei Absätze. Wenn ich jetzt erst mal zwei oder zweieinhalb Absätze irgendwie beschreibe, worum es überhaupt geht, und dann erst zum Punkt komme, das geht einfach gar nicht. Technologie-Themen sind leider für breite Bevölkerungsschichten immer noch relativ komplex.
Ist aber auch nachvollziehbar.
Ja, es ist nachvollziehbar, aber das macht es für uns ein bisschen schwieriger. Das ist halt auch eher so dieses Vakuum, wo Entscheidungen getroffen werden, die aber die nächsten 10, 20 Jahre als Rahmenbedingungen gelten und die uns in der Zukunft vor Probleme stellen, wenn mehr Leute Peil haben, worum es überhaupt geht, und feststellen, wir hätten uns eigentlich auch mal anders entscheiden können. Aber zurück zum AK-Vorrat. Also so 2005 war das, darf ich, auf dem Kongress. Da haben sich einfach so 20 Leute mal zusammengesetzt, so CTC, Fülburt, NNM und also so. Die üblichen Verdächtigen eigentlich, die es in Deutschland immer schon gab, so die üblichen 20, 30 Leute. Und wir meinten, wir müssen jetzt endlich mal was dagegen machen. Und der Vorteil war wohl damals, also damals war es ein Nachteil, aber wir haben eigentlich den Nachteil zum Vorteil gemacht. Wir hatten kein Geld, wir hatten keine Ressourcen. Also es war ja so gut wie keiner verdient sein Geld damit, dass er den ganzen Tag irgendwie sich um Politik kümmern kann. Jeder hat seine Jobs und sonstige Sachen, um die Miete zu verdienen. Und man macht das in der Freizeit, wie andere irgendwie Auto putzen. Und wir haben halt einfach unsere Tools genutzt, die wir kennen. Wir haben Mailinglisten genutzt, Wikis genutzt, wie wir es damals schon in der Kampagne gegen die Software-Patente gemacht haben. Und es war halt quasi wie so ein Open Source-Projekt. Jeder konnte mitmachen, jeder konnte sich engagieren. Das war halt so ein Trial-and-Error-Teil. Es wurden dann irgendwie Ideen entwickelt, irgendwelche neuen Leute kamen hinzu, konnten sich auch mitengagieren. Es war halt keine geschlossene Gesellschaft, sondern es war zum ersten Mal so auf deutscher Ebene, so hey, Datenschutz zu mitmachen.
Welche der Werkzeuge haben denn konkret gut funktioniert?
Wikis funktionieren sehr gut, um erst mal Informationen zusammenzustellen. Wikis funktionieren auch ganz gut, um Texte einfach mal kollaborativ zu schreiben, von Pressemitteilung bis sonstigen Sachen, aber vor allen Dingen so Sachen wie wir brauchen jetzt mal irgendwie eine Übersicht, welche Medien berichten über irgendwas. Klar, die Daten kriegt man aus Nus.Google irgendwie raus, Stichwort Vorratsdatensprecher und kriegt das auch als RSS-Feed, aber wenn du das ganze kollaborativ auslagerst, hier ist die Wikiseite und wer gerade Zeit und Lust hat, macht einfach den Pressespiegel zusammen, oder?
Die waren immer sehr ausführlich, das stimmt.
Ja, genau, also das einfach, wenn du nicht nur eine Person hast, die dafür verantwortlich ist, sondern wenn du das einfach als Task saß, hey, wer irgendwie Lust hat mitzumachen, macht da einfach was und tragt das dann ein, schaut, ob schon da ist oder nicht. Funktioniert so.
Da muss man auch nicht viel Arbeit beisteuern, oder?
Ja, genau. Eine andere Sache war, Blogs haben super funktioniert. Also eigentlich ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung als richtiges, gesellschaftliches Thema erst über die Blogs gelaufen.
Aber jetzt nicht über offizielle Blogs des AK, sondern überhaupt der gesamten Blogosphere.
Dezentral, also eine ganze Menge. Also wenn man sich halt anschaut, ist ja immer so der Vorwurf, deutsche Blogs sind unpolitisch, in den USA ist alles besser, was komischerweise von Journalisten in Deutschland immer gesagt wird, die halt aber nie auf deutsche Blogs verlinken, sondern immer nur auf US-Blogs und so weiter eine ganz andere Debatte. Aber wenn man sich halt das herrschende Thema in Deutschland, also politische Thema in den Blogs anschaut, dann ist das die Vorratsdatenspeicherung im letzten Jahr gewesen. Das denke ich auch. Und das war halt, das war von den einflussreichen Blogs, die eine große Reichweite haben, die eine gute Vernetzung waren, war das auf jeden Fall das Thema, was immer mehr Leute darauf aufmerksam gemacht hat. Das waren auch wiederum die Multiplikatoren, die geholfen haben, dass es an die Presse ging, dass Informationen schnell weiterverbreitet wurden. Das waren eigentlich unsere eigenen Infrastrukturen, die uns helfen, quasi neuere Entwicklungen einfach mal kollaborativ tief in die Breite über Netzwerke zu streuen. Und dann gab es dann immer so die Felder, dann heißt es ja auch Blogs, auch Online-Lease-Blogs, und die picken sich dann immer so die Sachen raus, die für sie interessant sind. Aber das sind eigentlich so frühwarn-Systeme. Und das war so ein Teil, das hatten wir früher noch nicht. Auch in der App-Kampagne gegen Software-Patente hatten wir keine Blog-Infrastrukturen und große Netzwerke, wo man Informationen verteilen kann. Also ein Beispiel, was ich immer so gerne herausstelle bei der Sache gegen die Vorwärtsartenspeicherung. Wir hatten unsere Großdemo da kurz vorher. Dann ging es in Diskussionen darum, wir brauchen ein Video, das wäre doch toll, weil YouTube ist jetzt da. Dann kommt ein Alexander Svenson, der schreibt aus blogwortfeld.de, ist ein freier Journalist für NDR und so weiter, und hat ein super geiles Video gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gemacht. Der hat sich einfach freie Inhalte aus archive.org geholt, so alte Prelinger Archiv-Filmafnahmen aus den 50er Jahren, aus US-Pernsesachen. Und hat daraus einen beeindruckenden 2,5 Minuten Film gemacht, der einen echt emotionalisiert und darauf hinweist, hey, mach mit bei der Verfassungsbeschwerde und sonst irgendwie, es geht um unsere Verbindungsdaten, es geht um die Protokollierung unserer ganzen Kommunikationsdaten und jetzt musst du dich einsetzen. Und das war halt so ein Werbeclip, der kam vollkommen aus einer Ecke, hat keiner erwartet, eine Agentur hätte eine ganze Menge Geld für investieren müssen, um so einen coolen Clip zu machen. Aber es sind halt so diese Sachen. Eine ganze Menge Leute von den Enden des Internets, so quasi mit denen man gar nicht gerechnet hat, die irgendwie sich als Teil dieses Netzwerks fühlen, bringen so ihre Qualitäten ein und probieren einfach aus. Also du hast einfach irgendwie, zehn Leute schmeißen ein Video rein so. Und acht sind schlecht, weil, naja, nicht jeder, also ich bin auch kein begabter Videokünstler, ich habe vielleicht manchmal Ideen, aber ich werde sicher das umgesetzt bekommen, bin ich alt. Aber dann gibt es halt andere Leute, die machen was und es funktioniert. Und das ist halt dieses Trial and Error. Du hast einfach so ein offenes System, genau wie in freie Software-Projekten oder bei Wikipedia oder sonst irgendwie. Ausprobieren, rausschmeißen.
Ja, ich meine, wir sehen es ja jetzt auch gerade im US-Präsidentschaftswahlkampf so. Ich erinnere an dieses Video, was der Kampagne von Barack Obama da extrem Aufschwung gegeben hat, auf Basis seiner Rede. Du weißt, was ich meine.
Ah ja, mit der, wo lauter Stars irgendwie dann Yes, we can.
Genau, wo sie das Yes, we can dann auch sozusagen Mantra-mäßig noch mal aufgreifen, aber dann halt auch überhaupt das Ganze noch mal in so einem kulturellen Kontext machen. Was mir jetzt aber auch noch einfällt, was jetzt bei der Vorratsdatensprechung extrem geholfen hat, war natürlich dieses krass starke Branding über dieses Stasi 2.0-Meme. Also das war, glaube ich, überhaupt so, das schon langsam zum Leitmotiv geworden.
Ja, das war, ich erinnere mich noch, wir hatten die erste Republika im Jahr 2007, letztes Jahr im April, und das war eine Woche bevor das Bundeskabinett die Vorratsdatensprechung beschlossen hat. Und wir brauchten unbedingt noch, oder wollten unbedingt noch Ideen haben und haben dann einen Workshop gemacht auf der Republika. Und ich war als Veranstalter da nicht dabei, aber die Räume bereitgestellt und bin danach irgendwie dahin. Und sie kommen alle strahlend raus und meinen, hey, wir haben einen Titel gefunden, Stasi 2.0. Und mir ist als wir die Klappe runtergefallen. Und ich dachte mir, ich könnte nicht machen, keine gute Idee. Von wegen irgendwie, naja gut, die Kritik kam ja auch berechtigt, dass man halt damit auch wiederum die Stasi, also dass es halt einfach nicht geht mit diesen historischen Vergleichen und so weiter. Aber im Endeffekt war es halt, dann gab es dann irgendwie das Blog datalune.de, die saßen auch in diesem Workshop drin, die haben dann diese Scheublone entwickelt und dann irgendwie zwei Tage später online gestellt. Das war halt dann, war irgendwie diese Kombination Stasi 2.0 und diese Scheublone war auf einmal diese Visualisierung. Und dann gab es da irgendwie, hat Datalune das Ganze in einem Spreadshirt-Shop gestellt und dann gab es noch ein bisschen Druck auf Spreadshirt, naja, sie sollten doch auch ihre Gewinne da reinspenden und dann hatten wir auf einmal 15.000 Euro aus irgendwie 10.000 verkauften oder weniger verkauften T-Shirts und wir hatten auf einmal Spielgeld, um halt diese Demo zu organisieren. Und auf einmal, man rannte auf Partys und sonst irgendwie und überall lächelte einen der Schäuble von dieser Schäuplone an. Und es gibt die mittlerweile auf Aufklebern, es gibt die auf Schäuplonen zum selber irgendwie besprühen und laufen durch Friedrichshain.
Ein echter Netz-Klassiker mittlerweile.
Also das war halt, ja, also im Endeffekt bin ich ganz froh, dass ich damals da nicht noch mehr irgendwie belabert hab, dass man das nicht machen könnte. Also das war halt...
Die Bedenkenträger.
Ja, also ich dachte halt echt so.
Ja, einfach auch ein bisschen was wagen. Ich glaube, das ist das, was man draus lernen kann. Und vor allem, das kann man gar nicht häufig genug betonen. Die Erfahrung hab ich halt auch gemacht, zum Beispiel jetzt bei der Organisation des Kongresses über die Jahre. Es ist einfach super wichtig, auch mal Leute einzuladen, ihren kreativen Output beizusteuern, die eigentlich so, wie vielleicht noch nicht mal im eigentlichen Sinne politisch sind, aber die auch schon gar nicht im eigentlichen Sinne technisch sind, sondern die einfach mit ihren künstlerischen Fähigkeiten so viel dazu beitragen können, dass so eine Kampagne erfolgreich ist. Einfach eben durch diese starken Logos, Meme, Videos, Songs, was auch immer. Also AK Vorrat hat ja auch diese, da sind ja auch diese großartigen Songs bei rausgekommen. Zwei, drei davon hab ich bei...
Ah, diese, ja, ja, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Wie hießen die denn noch gleich offiziell?
Ich hab sie Bundestag...
Bundestag United. Genau. Die hab ich irgendwie auch auf ChaosTV geballert. Die sind einfach gut. Also die bringen einfach vor allem die Debatte wunderbar präsent. Also mit den Original-Stimmen. Man hört auf einmal diese ganzen Tees. Man hört sich das an und denkt sich nur so, das können die noch nicht wirklich gesagt haben. Aber sie haben es halt gesagt.
Das ist so ein Grund, also ich bin ja ganz froh, dass Deutschlandradio und Deutschlandfunk zum Beispiel ihre ganzen Interviews und alles, was sie eigentlich produzieren, oder das meiste als MP3 online stellen. Und ich verlinke das eigentlich ganz gerne auf Netzpolitik. Und einfach, um halt auch den Leuten einfach mal Zeug an die Hand zu geben, hey, da gibt es einen Haufen cooles Material. Das kann man einfach mal remixen. Also ein anderes cooles Ding ist, es hat das Blog Spreeblick mal gemacht. Sie haben sich irgendwie, Wolfgang Schäuble präsentiert, irgendwie den neuen Fingerabdruckspass, ein Dächel in die Kamera, also wenn Politiker ins Internet sprechen. Und Spreeblick ist halt hingegangen und hat einfach mal irgendwie die Tonspuren ein bisschen geremixed und dann kam auf einmal was ganz anderes raus. Das sind halt so diese Sachen, die man dann auch wieder um das Netz laufen lassen kann.
ChaosCV 97, wer das nochmal nachschlagen will, braucht hier eine der meistgeladenen Dateien.
Also im Endeffekt, ich meine, wir haben die Werkzeuge, wir können damit kreativ umgehen. Und jeder hat irgendwelche Stärken. Und die einen können halt besser mit Politikern reden, die anderen können halt Mesh-ups machen, und die Dritten, die können cool designen und so weiter. Wenn du das alles zusammenschmeißt, wenn du das Ganze irgendwie in Netzwerken denkst, also wie so ein Open-Source-Projekt funktioniert ja auch so, dass halt irgendwie, gut, es gibt Maintainer, ähnlich wie bei der Wikipedia die Administratoren oder Moderatoren, die versuchen, das in eine Bahn zu lenken, die sind ein bisschen engagierter und haben so einen Überblick. Aber im Endeffekt, jeder kann teilnehmen und du hast halt so einen Trial-and-Error-Teil und kannst halt immer weiter ausprobieren und die guten Sachen setzen sich einfach durch. So, guter Code setzt sich in einem Open-Source-Projekt durch gegenüber schlechter. Aber dadurch, dass jeder mitmachen kann, hast du einfach viel mehr irgendwie Auswahl.
Aber jetzt kommt die Einschränkung. So cool diese ganzen Sachen sind, wir wissen, die Mobilisierung, die man erreicht, geht eigentlich, also die erreicht, die Unterstützerszene, doppelt und dreifach, und das ist der eigentliche Gewinn. Aber der Sache selbst ist damit noch nicht geholfen. Teilweise, gerade was jetzt diese Stasi 2.0-Geschichte betrifft, das war sicherlich so deine Einschränkung, in der öffentlichen Diskussion kann natürlich so ein hartes Topic, was man da, vor allem so krasse Vergleiche, die historisch immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu bewerten sind, muss das ja nicht unbedingt von Vorteil sein. Also gerade was so eine Szene mobilisiert, ist dann nicht unbedingt in der öffentlichen Auseinandersetzung wirklich hilfreich. Ich weiß nicht, was das jetzt hier konkret für eine Auswirkung gehabt hat, aber das bringt mich quasi jetzt zu meiner nächsten Frage. Was war denn dann jetzt sozusagen wirklich hilfreich in der öffentlichen Auseinandersetzung über die eigentlich unterstützte Szene hinaus? Also wie hat der AK Vorrat da seinen Ansatz gewählt und was hat da funktioniert und was hat nicht funktioniert?
Hilfreich waren verschiedene Aspekte. Erstmal haben wir Bündnis auf die Beine gestellt, was nach außen hin ein breites gesellschaftliches Bündnis symbolisierte. Ich sag symbolisierte, weil wenn du da eine Liste hast mit 50 großen Organisationen, wenn du die auf dem Papier zusammenzählst, kannst du da herausfinden, na gut, theoretisch hat man jetzt irgendwie die halbe Gesellschaft ein Mitglieder hinter sich. Nur ein paar verschiedene Gewerkschaften, da sind ja schon 10 Millionen oder so. In der Praxis bedeutet das dann halt eine große Gewerkschaft. Da hat man halt irgendjemanden, der irgendwie das gut findet, was man da macht, und der schiebt dann halt seinen Bundesvorstand irgendwie eine Entscheidungsvorlage irgendwie vor der Bundesvorstand, sagt halt, ja, finden wir gut, aber dann steht halt der Name der großen Gewerkschaft auf der Liste. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass die irgendwie ein bisschen dafür tun, vielleicht geben sie mal eine Pressemitteilung raus, aber es gibt ja weder finanzielle noch sonstige Sachen. Aber es wirkt erstmal viel seriöser, wenn du halt einfach gegenüber Journalisten sagen kannst, hey, wir haben Gewerkschaften, wir haben Parteien, wir haben irgendwie die Hacker, wir haben die und die, und wir sind eigentlich von links radikal bis irgendwie leicht rechts, haben wir einfach alles abgedeckt, also wir sind nicht die Spinner. Das war ein großer Vorteil, aber es war halt auch der Nachteil ist halt, das ist nicht wirklich nachhaltig und sonst irgendwie, aber so funktioniert Deutschland. Also du schaffst darüber halt Vertrauen. Eine andere Sache waren halt irgendwie die, eigentlich eine gute Sache, die Demonstration, die Kosten, Unmengen an Energien. Also so eine Demo zu organisieren, das ist ja äußerst aufwendig und dann kann es ja auch, eigentlich ist es ja auch so ein Würfelspiel, ich meine regnet es oder quittert es an so einer Demo, dann ist die ganze Vorbereitung irgendwie für die Katz. Für Labor? Vielleicht. Aber wenn es halt klappt, dann hast du halt einfach 15.000 Leute bei der dritten Demo irgendwie auf der Straße und hast die größte Demo geführt, Datenschutz seit 20 Jahren. Damals fehlten zwar die Medien, weil sie das eigentlich auch kaum gecovert haben, aber im Nachhinein hat das schon irgendwie, wenn man halt immer darauf hinweist, hey, das war einfach die größte Demo seit 20 Jahren, es gibt eine neue Datenschutzbewegung, dann ist es auf einmal wieder, ja, das könnte ja doch interessant sein, darüber zu berichten, weil das sind nicht nur ein paar Spinner, die irgendwo hingehen, sondern das sind 15.000 Leute, ich meine, es gibt nicht viele Demos, also wenn es einen Irak-Krieg gibt, dann gehen 500.000 Leute auf die Straße, um eine Kerze hinzuhalten, aber sonst geht auch keiner mehr auf die Straße. Also das war ein Vorteil, aber es war auch gleichzeitig irgendwie, ja, es bindet halt eine ganze Menge, eine ganze Menge Ressourcen. Was auch ein großer Vorteil war, irgendwie die Klage gegen, beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, wo der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatensprechung einfach die größte Massenklage ever in Deutschland auf die Beine gestellt hat, und wir haben da 35.000 Menschen dazu bekommen, etwas zu unterschreiben, größtenteils sogar noch irgendwie einzuschicken. Dann gab es Freiwillige, die haben das alles sortiert und sonst irgendwie und beim Bundesverfassungsgericht eingereicht. Das sind natürlich auch immer Zahlen, das kannst du von der Kampagne. Kampagnenmäßig kannst du ja immer, wenn du das immer ein halbes Jahr laufen lässt, kannst du ja jede Woche eine neue Pressemitteilung rausgeben. Jetzt haben wir schon 5.000, jetzt haben wir schon 8.000, jetzt haben wir schon 10.000 und zum Schluss 35.000. Das ist ja immer was Fortlaufendes. Also der Arbeitskreis Vorzahnsprechung hat auch sehr regelmäßig und macht immer noch sehr regelmäßig Pressemitteilung einfach. Und wird geschaut, okay, können wir jetzt irgendwas Relevantes irgendwie als Meldung machen? Nicht alles ist eine Meldung so wert, aber sehr oft.
Diese großen Zahlen, ich hatte den Eindruck, das hat die Medien auch geradezu gezwungen, darüber zu berichten. Also es war einfach auf ein Level gekommen, wo man es nicht mehr ignorieren konnte.
Genau, verbunden mit größter Massenklage überhaupt so. Das sind einfach Dinge. Parallel dazu haben die ganzen Medien ja auch festgestellt, sie haben da auch ein Problem mit, mit ihrer Pressefreiheit, dass die auf einmal irgendwie von wegen Informantenschutz und so weiter und Quellenschutz, dass die halt...
Haben sich denn journalistische Verbände auch der AK-Vorratsdatenspeicherung angeschlossen?
Ja, genau, also auf dem Papier.
Viele? Welche nennenswerten?
So viele gibt es da ja nicht, aber ich glaube, auf jeden Fall der DJV, der DJU und so, was es da so gibt, die waren dabei.
Hatte aber trotzdem nicht den Eindruck, dass die Medienfront nun wirklich Stimmung gemacht hat.
Ja, das war leider das Traurige.
Das habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden.
Sie haben es eigentlich, also das war ja erstmal schön.
Haben die es nicht verstanden?
Sie haben es, sie haben es teilweise echt nicht verstanden. Und dann ist es halt, das Thema ist ja nicht besonders sexy, ich meine, es ist ja viel sexier, irgendwie jahrelang mit der Gesundheitsreform irgendwie zu reden, die keiner mehr versteht.
Ja, aber wenn ein Journalist verhaftet wird, irgendwie im Ausland. Ja, aber warum macht es der Spiegel nicht?
Ja, frag mich nicht. Also ich glaube, in den letzten drei, vier Jahren oder in der ganzen Geschichte der Vorratsdatensprechung ist drei oder viermal irgendwie auf hinteren Seiten über die Vorratsdatensprechung berichtet worden. Muss ich mir jetzt nicht fragen. Ich bin da nicht in der Redaktion drin und keine Ahnung.
Ja gut, aber du bist ja schon so an der politischen Front und darüber reden wir ja auch. Und da halte ich jetzt für eine berechtigte Frage, warum diese Botschaften manchmal auch einfach nicht ankommen.
Warum kommen sie nicht an? Naja, einerseits, also diese ganzen Zusammenschlüsse, das sind jetzt keine fetten PR-Profis. Also wie gesagt, ein Arbeitskreis für Uhrzeitensprechungen besteht aus einem Haufen Freiwilliger. Die stellen eine ganze Menge echt super Sachen auf die Beine. Aber ja, es verdient ja noch nicht mal irgendjemand irgendwie sein Geld damit, außer jetzt beim Fürbud.
War denn das eine Diskussion? Sich vielleicht auch mal so einen Kampagnenleiter zu finanzieren aus diesen Spenden?
Das ist das große Problem, was der VORATZ-Datensprechung im Moment hat. Es war eine lange Diskussion. Gründet man jetzt mal einen Verein daraus, sieht man das als offenes Bündnis. Es ist eigentlich eine typische politische Diskussion, wenn man Bündnisse hat. Das funktioniert bei ATTAK genauso wie beim Arbeitskreis VORATZ-Datensprechung. Es hat früher in sämtlichen Zusammenhängen genauso funktioniert. Irgendwann ist der große Streit da, lassen wir es jetzt basisdemokratisch, jeder darf mitentscheiden, oder schaffen wir einfach kampanientfähige Infrastrukturen. Es gibt einen Grund, warum Greenpeace ein relativ undemokratisches Modell fährt, dafür aber PR-technisch und marketingtechnisch sehr fit ist, sehr kampanientfähig ist. Und andere Umweltverbände, die ein sehr demokratisches System haben, eigentlich kaum draußen in Erscheinung treten, weil die erst einmal alles ausdiskutieren und sich erst einmal über eine Entscheidung zerstreiten. Das Problem hat der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung im Moment auch. Da gibt es extreme Standpunkte. Die einen sagen, jeder Entscheidung muss auf der Mailing-Nist oder am Wiki aus 1.500 Leuten, die da drauf sind, zusammengefällt werden. Es gibt auch andere, die sagen, wir sind bis 2015 mit der Diskussion fertig, wir müssen eine Demo organisieren. Dann muss man einfach mal was machen. Nicht erst einmal alles ausdiskutieren. Für viele mag das jetzt groß Probleme darstellen, aber das kommt in sämtlichen politischen Bereichen vor. Wenn du ein offenes Netzwerk hast und dann mal schaust, kann man da, es gibt dann die Leute, die sehen, wir müssen hier mal Strukturen reinbringen, um effizienter arbeiten zu können. Andererseits hast du dann immer sofort die Grundsatzdebatte und das Leben und alles andere.
Das kenn ich. Vielleicht zum Abschluss. Es wurde eine Menge bewegt, es gab die Demos. Es kam dann eben auch zum Schiedsspruch des Bundesverfassungsgerichts.
Nein, es kam zu einer Vorentscheidung. Diese Vorentscheidung war auch erst mal so, dass die Anträge durchgelesen worden sind. Bis zur endgültigen Behandlung, was jetzt im Herbst stattfinden wird, nach der Sommerpause, hat man erst mal entschieden, dass die Verbindungsdaten nur in schwersten kriminellen Fällen genutzt werden dürfen.
Ich habe gerade etwas durcheinander gebracht. Die Online-Durchsuchung hatte ein relativ klares Urteil, dass das Gesetz verfassungswidrig war. Die Vorwärtsdatenspeicherungsgeschichte, diese vorläufige, kam ja dann kurz danach. Man hatte auch den Eindruck, dass da schon das Echo mit drin war. Eigentlich müsste man ja auch noch diesen Kampf gegen die Online-Durchsuchung an der Stelle erwähnen. Da gab es eine Klage, die jetzt nicht 33.000 Unterstützer hat, aber das ist ja auch beim Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich Schnuppe. Für die Medien mag das interessant sein, für die öffentliche Wirkung, aber einer reicht. Das war ja eigentlich auch sehr wagemutig, da vorzugehen. Das kostet ja auch Zeit und im Zweifelsfall eben auch Geld.
Ja genau, das ist lustigerweise. Viele kennen ja wahrscheinlich die Electronic Frontier Foundation aus den USA. Die IFF, die größte Digital Rights-Bürgerrechtsorganisation weltweit. Ich habe dann auch immer gedacht, die machen da für die fetten Kampagnen und sonst irgendwie. Irgendwann habe ich noch ein bisschen mehr Einblick bekommen und habe halt kapiert, die beschäftigen einfach von den 17 Mitarbeitern 14 Anwälte und die klagen einfach gegen alles. Das wurde mir so erklärt, wir haben Bush, da kann man halt nichts anderes machen. Politik beeinflussen geht überhaupt nicht. Unser einziger Weg ist, Anwälte zu finanzieren und vor Gericht zu gehen, das alles niederzuklagen auf unsere Grundrechte. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die wir auch in den letzten Jahren in Deutschland haben. Die politischen Prozesse, die kann man auch vor vier Jahren fest auf EU-Ebene, als EU-Minister das irgendwie ausgekaspert haben. Da kann man eigentlich auch nur noch Geld sparen und zusammenschmeißen und dann vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht gehen. Eigentlich sollte Politik viel demokratischer sein, vorher sollte viel mehr Entscheidungsspielraum da sein für die mitentscheidenden Politikern, aber das System ist halt so, dass du dann eigentlich kaum noch Gestaltungsmöglichkeit hast und dann zum Schluss soll das Bundesverfassungsgericht dann nochmal feststellen, das nochmal irgendwie gerade biegen in die Verfassung rein. Was ein Paradoxon ist, aber leider die Realität, aber deswegen ist es halt wichtig und sinnvoll, dass es Anwälte gibt, dass es auch Menschen gibt, die halt sagen, ich nehme jetzt irgendwie das alles in Kauf irgendwie. Man schickt ja nicht einfach mal eine Verfassungsbeschwerde ein und wartet dann auf Ergebnis, sondern es ist ja mit einer ganzen Menge Engagement verbunden und auch teilweise mit Geldeinsatz verbunden, einfach diese Verfassungsbeschwerde durchzufechten. Aber da kommt dann in der Regel, wenn man das Ganze gut formuliert so und die richtigen Partner hat, kommt in der Regel ja was Sinnvolles bei heraus. Also zumindest was Sinnvolles für unsere Bürgerrechte.
Jetzt zurück zur Entscheidung über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Du hast gesagt, es gibt jetzt eine Vorentscheidung. Steht im Prinzip noch mal eine große Debatte im Herbst an, wenn dann final darüber geurteilt wird, ob das an sich zulässig ist. Das ist auch eine schwierige, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie das so ausformuliert ist. Geht es da im Prinzip auch noch mal um eine Abwägung, ob überhaupt die EU da für uns was reglementieren darf?
Das sind verschiedenste Bereiche, über die irgendwie mitentschieden wird. Auch vom EU-Gerichtshof liegt eine Klage von Irland vor, ob dieser EU-Rat überhaupt in der Lage war, darüber zu bestimmen oder nicht. Also das ist erst mal so eine Grundfrage. Dann ist halt die weitere Grundfrage, ist die jetzt überhaupt verfassungskonform? Oder ist Europa dafür zuständig? Und das Deutsche Bundesverfassungsgericht kann so größtenteils seine Arbeit aufgeben oder sonst irgendwie. Das ist eine äußerst komplexe Fragestellung anhand des Beispiels Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was aber im Endeffekt durch diese Komplexität Auswirkungen auf ganz viele Dinge haben würde. Deswegen ist es halt relativ schwierig vorherzusagen, wie es ausgehen würde. Also so ist halt dieser typische Joke, wenn man mit zwei Juristen redet, hat man drei Meinungen. Aber da macht es halt noch ein bisschen komplizierter. Aber es gibt eine ganze Menge Journalisten, die halt echt der Meinung sind, das kann eigentlich nicht so konform sein. Aber dann spielt halt immer noch diese konstante Europa da rein, was halt wiederum irgendwie der Stich sein kann, dass Europarecht jetzt wiederum über unserem Grundgesetz steht und so weiter. Und dann das Ganze aussticht. Und ja, wir werden sehen, also ich hoffe sehr, dass dem ein Riegel vorgeworfen wird und dass halt im Optimalfall irgendwie die Vorratsratenspeicherung im Grundgesetz widrig ist.
Was auch nicht so ganz unwahrscheinlich ist.
Also sonst hätten da nicht 35.000 Leute mit unterschrieben und sonst würden da nicht so viele Juristen der Meinung sein. Das geht so und nicht.
Ja, gibt es noch weitere Lehren, die man jetzt so aus diesem AK-Projekt ziehen kann? Also, wir hatten es im Prinzip schon. Es ist immer wirklich so eine grundsätzliche Frage, wie beteiligt man sich. Hier gab es im Prinzip auch so eine Kulmination, weil die Vorratsratenspeicherung ist natürlich auch immer wieder der totale Mega-Gau. Aber es zieht uns ja auch immer im Kleinen. Welche Organisationsstruktur soll man sich eben suchen, um überhaupt... Du bist ja auch Aktivist im weiteren Sinne. Du versuchst ja auch irgendwie Einfluss zu nehmen. Was ist denn deine Organisationsform? Was ist dein Weg, diesen Einfluss auch auszuüben? Jetzt mal abgesehen von Blogs und Podcasts und Öffentlichkeit nutzen, Tools und Wikis, also jetzt so konkret. Wie klopft man an bei der Politik? Wie macht man denen klar, dass das so nicht geht?
Du hast tatsächlich einen schon angesprochen, weil wahrscheinlich meine größte Aktivismus-Form ist Publizität. Also einfach über Dinge berichten, einen Filter darstellen als Anlaufpunkt, um andere Menschen wiederum diesen Filter zur Verfügung zu stellen, über das Thema auf dem Laufenden zu sein, Kommentare abzugeben zu aktuellen Entwicklungen, durch meine Podcasts und Videopodcasts eine Art Bildungsfernsehen bereitzustellen. Darüber erreicht man wiederum eine ganze Menge andere Multiplikatoren. Was wir bei Netzpolitik leisten, ist einerseits ein Schulungsprogramm für Menschen, die Interesse daran haben, den Debatten zu folgen, auf dem Laufenden zu sein. Andererseits, ich weiß von ganz vielen Journalisten, die lesen das einfach, weil wir erledigen die Hälfte ihrer Arbeit. Diese anderen Medien erreichen dann spätestens die Politik, weil Öffentlichkeit hergestellt wird.
Aber so einen direkten Kontakt zur Politik gibt es nicht?
Doch, habe ich auch, klar. Und wie geht das dann ab? Es gibt Parteien, die hören einfach nicht auf mich. Es bringt nicht viel, wenn ich da besuche.
Gehst du zu denen oder kommen die zu dir?
In der Regel gehe ich zu denen. Die wenigsten kommen zu mir. Ich gehe zu Veranstaltungen, zu Aufschusssitzungen. Ich versuche, da in Kontakt zu treten. Ich habe relativ wenig Kontakt mit Abgeordneten selbst, eher mit den Mitarbeitern. Es gibt auch Mitarbeiter, die rufen regelmäßig an und fragen nach. Also Mitarbeiter von Abgeordneten auf Bundesebene oder Landesebene? Genau, mehr auf Bundesebene. Es gibt dann meist EU-Ebene. Meistens muss ich denen hinterhertelefonieren. Ich muss sie dann versuchen zu erreichen und ihnen zu erklären, dass es da ein kleines Problem gibt. Das ist die eine Sache. Andererseits gibt es Möglichkeiten wie Konsultationen mit der Zivilgesellschaft. So nennt man alles, was nicht Regierung ist und was nicht Wirtschaft ist. Das gibt es vor allen Dingen bei Prozessen auf internationaler Ebene. Da trifft man sich dann mit Ministeriumsmitarbeitern, die in die Bundesrepublik Deutschland in internationalen Verhandlungen treffen, vertreten und die treffen sich halt vorher mit der Wirtschaft. Dann wird halt mal die Zivilgesellschaft eingeladen, dann darf man mal seinen Kommentar abgeben, dann wird er wieder rausgeschmissen, dann reden sie weiter mit der Wirtschaft. Also das war in der Regel meine Erfahrung, aber dann hat man auch schon mal irgendwie in der Ministerialbürokratie Ansprechpartner, wo man dann auch mal irgendwie hinterfragen kann. Dann gibt es natürlich auch die Situation, da trifft man sich halt mit Menschen zu Hintergrundgesprächen oder sonst irgendwie beim Bier. Oder man trifft sich auf Veranstaltungen und nutzt halt irgendwie das Bier zu Hintergrundgesprächen und kriegt dann mal ein bisschen mehr Einblick oder ein paar Informationen, die halt recht wichtig wären. Oder man kann halt ein bisschen mehr mal irgendwie andere Hintergründe, technische Hintergründe, so vermitteln. Gelingt das?
Also ich meine, das würde mich ja immer interessieren. Ich meine, jetzt hat man einfach Kontakt mit den Mitarbeitern. Was erzählt man denen?
Das kommt ja ganz auf den Gesetzesprozess an.
Okay, dann sage ich mal, woran sind die interessiert? Also was ist deren Bedarf, den man denken muss?
Also sagen wir mal, in diesem...
Wie erzeugt man die Aufmerksamkeit?
Im Netzpolitikbereich ist es halt erstmal so Wissensvermittlung. Die wissen auch meistens gar nicht, worum es geht. Ich meine, viele Mitarbeiter, die haben halt politische Wissenschaften studiert und dann kriegen sie halt einen Job, weil sie irgendwie Politikwissenschaften studiert haben. Dann funktioniert es genauso, du wirst in den Bundestag gewählt und entweder wird dir was zugelost, du bist jetzt Tourismuspolitischer Sprecher oder Medienpolitischer Sprecher, weil kein anderer will es machen. Und dann bist du halt Medienpolitischer Sprecher. Und die kriegen neue Mitarbeiter und der ist halt ein Assistent vom Medienpolitischen Sprecher. Hat vielleicht über Rundfunk und Fernsehen irgendwie mal bei der Uni was gelernt, aber muss sich dann auf einmal mit freier Software beschäftigen oder sonstigen Dingen. Und du versuchst ihnen dann erst mal die Hintergründe irgendwie relativ nicht technisch zu vermitteln. Du versuchst ihnen halt einfach zu erklären, worum es umgeht. Weil wir sonst versuchen das halt selbst irgendwie herauszufinden. Und das Ergebnis sieht man halt in der Regel, wie halt Politik irgendwie gemacht wird.
Wobei weiß man jetzt, mit welchem Abgeordneten man reden muss. Muss man alle durchtelefonieren, einfach mal so die Extensions durchzählen.
Naja, also es ist relativ klar, dass ich mit dem Tourismuspolitischen Sprecher einer Fraktion irgendwie nicht so viel anfangen kann. Das wäre halt erstmal vergebene Liebesmüh, es sei denn, dass es mein Wahlkreisabgeordneter ist. Dann habe ich einen anderen Bezug zu ihm. Also entweder habe ich einen lokalen Bezug zu ihm, dann kann ich jetzt sagen, hey, ich habe sie direkt gewählt, oder ich könnte sie direkt wählen oder sonst irgendwie.
Oder ich könnte aufhören, sie direkt zu wählen.
Genau. Also im Endeffekt, ja, das ist Abgeordneten sehr wichtig. Vor allen Dingen aus den beiden großen Parteien, weil die Hälfte von denen kommt halt über Direktmandat. Andererseits halt thematischer Bezug. Also die Abgeordneten sitzen in einem Ausschuss, wo einfach dieses Gesetz irgendwie, das jeweilige Gesetz behandelt wird.
Welche Ausschüsse sind so die wichtigsten für netzpolitische Themen?
Leider der Rechtsausschuss, was dazu führt, dass halt ein Haufen Juristen irgendwie ohne jegliches technisches Verständnis die Gesetze machen. Dann wir haben einen Kultur- und Medienausschuss mit einem Unterausschuss Neue Medien.
Also wir reden jetzt wieder vom Bundestag.
Genau, der Unterausschuss Neue Medien ist wiederum ja, also da geht es, das ist der Netzpolitik-Ausschuss, aber der hat auch wiederum mehr oder weniger eine beratende Funktion.
Unterausschuss heißt, der ist einem anderen Ausschuss untergeordnet.
und Medienausschuss. Kultur und Medien, da gibt es ja von Theaterförderung bis, keine Ahnung, ARD, ZDF, bis...
Okay, und der Unterausschuss heißt?
Unterausschuss Neue Medien.
Ach so, ich meine, was ist der über?
Kulturen Medien. Genau, und der Unterausschuss Neue Medien, da wird halt über Netzpolitik im weitesten Sinne irgendwie geredet. Aber der hat ja auch mehr oder weniger nur... Also die können ja was beschließen, was wird dann um Kulturen Medienausschuss vorgelegt? Und das ist eigentlich der wichtige Ausschuss. Da gibt es halt teilweise Überschneidungen.
Wie viele von diesen Sitzungen sind wirklich öffentlich?
Weiß ich nicht, in der Regel vielleicht jeder Zweite. Also es gibt auch schon Sitzungen. Also eine ganze Menge Sitzungen, da wollte ich hin. Die sind halt nicht öffentlich. Manchmal wird man dann über irgendwelche Abgeordneten, die man halt kennt, die nehmen halt einen mit. Dann darf man halt nicht so mit tippen und so weiter.
Gibt es die Aufzeichnung eigentlich der Aufschüsse?
Es gibt zumindest von den Öffentlichen Protokolle. Die brauchen eine Zeit lang, bis sie dann mal online stehen. Aber die Öffentlichen sind zumindest fotografiert.
Aber es wird doch auch gerade das Video aufgezeichnet, oder nicht?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Das ist auch der Running Gag. Ich habe auch schon öfters mal angefragt, ob ich mit meiner Kamera vorbeikommen kann, bei Ausschusssitzungen zu Vorratenspeicherung und das Ganze aufzeichnen darf. Und? Gibt nicht. Es wurde immer damit argumentiert. Da haben sich tatsächlich ein paar Mal Ausschüsse die Vorstände eines Ausschusses, also es sind dann halt ein paar aus jeder Fraktion einer, und die treffen sich immer um die Tagesordnung vorzulegen. Und die haben das tatsächlich dann öfters so mal beschlossen. Es wurde immer mit den Persönlichkeitsrechten der Ausschussreferenten abgelehnt.
Also der eingeladenen Gäste.
Genau, man muss sich das so vorstellen, man macht eine Anhörung zu einem Thema Vorratsansprechung. Man lernt, jede Fraktion darf dann einen Experten einladen. Die Großen dürfen meistens zwei einladen. Und dann wählt man halt einen sich irgendwie genehmigen Experten ein, der dann die eigene Meinung vertritt, so am besten. Und dem stellt man dann noch ein paar Fragen. Das ist halt so eine riesige Demokratiesimulation, weil das Ergebnis steht eh schon vorher fest. Und dann meinte ich halt so, ja kann man das nicht mal transparent machen, sondern ich komme auch gerne mit meiner Kamera vorbei, wenn ihr das halt nicht aufzeichnet. Ich kann das gern machen, ich kann das auch liebend gerne unter freien Lizenzen online stellen und einfach zugänglich machen. Das kostet euch nichts und ihr habt gar keine Arbeit. Das wurde halt mit den Persönlichkeitsrechten dieser Referenten abgelehnt.
Das ist unglaublich, weil in diesen Ausschussräumen ist eine absurde Technik installiert, um aufzunehmen. Kameras ohne Ende, aus jedem Winkel, Mikrofone.
Also eigentlich kann man damit argumentieren. Es muss jetzt nicht die Videoform sein, es können ja auch die Audioform sein, wenn wir was aufzeichnen. Bei der Videoform kann man halt argumentieren, na gut, dann Leute, wenn sie von der Kamera stehen, dann fühlen sich ein bisschen mehr beobachtet und so. Aber im Endeffekt, hey, das ist ein demokratischer...
Es ist ein demokratischer Ausschuss.
Ja genau, es ist ein demokratischer Ort, da werden Entscheidungen gefällt.
Das gefällt der Bevölkerung gefällt.
Und dann sollte man doch versuchen, das möglichst irgendwie transparent zu machen. Ich meine, wenn man immer in so einer Ausschusssitzung drin sitzt, dann hat das schon leicht skurrile Züge gemacht. Also da kann man auch wieder Verschwörungstheorien heranziehen und sagen, ja, die wissen schon, warum sie das nicht machen, weil die einen Abgeordneten pöbeln rum, die anderen popeln in der Nase und die anderen sind überhaupt gar nicht da. Die Abgeordneten oder die Ausschuss, also die geladenen Experten, die labern auch manchmal Unsinn, wo man das Gefühl hat, die wissen jetzt auch nicht so genau, worum es überhaupt geht. Ja, aber eigentlich, also zumindest ist da...
Das ist die Wahrheit, die muss irgendwie ans Licht.
Ja, oder zumindest ist es mein politischer Anspruch von Transparenz so, dass man halt, hey, wir haben die Werkzeuge jetzt da und da kann leider nicht jeder sitzen und so weiter und wieso nutzen wir jetzt nicht diese Möglichkeiten, also es wird...
Vielleicht wollen wir ein AK-Ausschuss-Aufzeichnung.
Ja, also man kann auch einfach irgendwie, wir sind auch schon hingegangen und haben irgendwie eine interne Sitzung irgendwie live-geschrieben ins Netz, so wenn es da WLAN gab, so ist das manchmal.
Mit Audio.
Ja, manchmal bei Konsultationen der Bundesregierung, wo dann nur Lobbyisten eingeladen werden.
Gab es da mal Reaktionen auf die Veröffentlichungen?
Ne, gar nichts, da ging es auch immer um Urheberrechte und so. Da mussten wir uns auch mal selbst einladen, damit wir überhaupt hin dürfen und dann standen dann um uns herum die ganzen Lobbyisten der Filmindustrie und Musikindustrie.
Aber ich meine, wenn das jetzt bei netzpolitik.org gepostet wurde...
Da warte ich ja immer darauf, dass sich irgendwer mal beschmiert.
Weil die es nicht mitbekommen oder weil sie es einfach wegignorieren oder keine Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen wollen?
Irgendwas von beiden. Also entweder kriegen sie es nicht mit oder irgendwer kriegt es mit und denkt sich, das ist ja lustig oder ein Dritter merkt halt, na gut, wir haben ein Problem, wir können ja nichts tun, weil das bringt ja dann noch mehr Aufmerksamkeit drauf. Aber im Endeffekt, also wenn irgendwie ein Presse- und Informationsamt der deutschen Bundesregierung, da finden öfter solche nicht öffentlichen irgendwie Anhörungen der Bundesregierung statt, wer da irgendwie mal hingeht, da gibt es WLAN. Und das WLAN ist offen. Und normalerweise die ganzen Lobbyisten, ein Presse- und Informationsamt, das ist direkt an der Friedrichstraße. Und um einen rum sitzen dann Herr Scharn von Lobbyisten, alle in teuren Anzügen, alle mit ihrem Blog und Papier. Und man wird so einen Notebook aufklappen und live auf Sendung gehen. Und das macht eigentlich recht viel Spaß.
Ja, in Zeiten von Mogulus und Ustream und anderen Diensten, alles kein Problem mehr. Fällt vielleicht ein bisschen auf, wenn man seinen Laptop immer falsch rumhält, damit die Kamera...
Ja, manchmal hat man dann so andere Probleme, dann fängt das Notebook in einer Stunde an, irgendwie laut zu röhren, weil der Lüfter irgendwie leicht kaputt ist.
Na gut, aber es gibt ja in der Tat auch brauchbare Technik, die man da so ran... Man muss ja nicht immer gleich eingebaute Mikrofone benutzen, sondern da gibt es ja auch Spionagetechnologie, die kann man ja dann vielleicht auch machen.
Genau, und im Endeffekt, ich meine, die Ausschusssitzung, UMTS ist immer verbreiteter und wenn jetzt endlich die Notebooks auch mal ein bisschen bessere Akkus noch haben, die Sitzung dauern in der Regel drei Stunden, dann sitzt man zwar total beengt da, aber dann kann man halt einfach in so einer Ausschusssitzung live auf Sendung gehen und wenn du dann nicht gerade die Kamera offen hinhälst, dann einfach zivilen Ungehorsam zeigen und das machen.
Ja, gute Idee. Weil ich würde das gerne, also ich, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mir da nicht wirklich die Dora Gedanken gemacht. Als ich da letztens in diesem Ausschuss saß, war da wirklich, also wirklich eine monströse Aufzeichnungstechnik am Start. Da dachte ich mir so, oh ja super, wird ja alles getapet. Aber ich hatte auch noch nicht den Ort gefunden, wo es ins Netz gegossen wird und das wird halt auch nicht getan. Ich meine, sie machen Aufzeichnungen, aber sie machen die Aufzeichnung dann vom Protokoll, also das Protokoll von den Aufzeichnungen oder von einer Live-Beobachtung?
Also entweder sie machen ein Live-Protokoll, so war das zumindest früher üblich, aber bei den letzten habe ich keine Protokollantinnen mehr gesehen. Also wahrscheinlich machen sie Aufzeichnungen und dann protokolliert das irgendwer im Hinterzimmer.
Aber die Protokolle, umfassen die alles oder das wesentliche Geschehen? Also wird da der Wortlaut notiert?
Die umfassen alles, manchmal auch irgendwie XY bringt da irgendwie eine Bemerkung oder Gejubel bei Fraktion XY.
Aber das wird auch nicht veröffentlicht?
Doch, doch, das findet man dann in den Protokollen drin.
Okay, das heißt, man hat das Wort, das gesprochene Wort, ist nachvollziehbar?
Genau, das gesprochene Wort in schriftlicher Form.
Wo findet man das?
Ja, auf den Seiten der jeweiligen Bundestagsausschüsse. Da gibt es dann halt Protokolle und da ist dann immer in der Regel braucht es halt ein paar Tage, aber dann steht es online. Das funktioniert bei allen anderen Ebenen genau so. Also wahrscheinlich auf kommunaler Ebene braucht es immer am längsten, weil die haben am wenigsten Ressourcen. Im EU-Parlament muss ja alles immer sofort in zig Sprachen übersetzt werden. Das dauert es teilweise auch ein bisschen länger, aber ja, mehr genug.
Ja, aber Protokolllesen ist natürlich ungemein anstrengender, als einfach eine Aufzeichnung zu verfolgen. Von daher könnte sich da durchaus was tun.
Genau, ich fände es ja auch irgendwie netter. Ich meine, man kann ja auch aus Protokollen irgendwie das Beste rauskopieren und zusammen mixen zu einem Text oder einfach nur mal die besten Zitate posten. Da gibt es ja auch teilweise echt lustige Rededuelle. Aber warum das nicht mal mit Audio-Sachen machen? Das kommt ja viel cooler, wenn die Beleidigungen von bestimmten Abgeordneten dann mal live auf Tape sind. Statt dass man sie irgendwie liest.
Für das nächste Mash-up und den nächsten Protest-Song.
Ja, aber auch ansonsten, du sitzt halt, du hörst in deinem mobilen MP3-Player, du hörst in einer Ausschusssitzung an. Ich meine, das macht auch nicht jeder, aber man sollte doch zumindest das Angebot bereitstellen.
Klar, ich finde das interessant. So, jetzt denke ich, sollten wir nochmal in die Zukunft schauen oder vielmehr eigentlich ein bisschen mehr in die Gegenwart, was sich gerade so tut. Und es tut sich mal wieder leider, muss man sagen, eine Menge. Ich habe es schon eingangs erwähnt, so wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die Online-Durchsuchung uns in den letzten Jahren heimgesucht hat oder zumindest versucht hat, uns heimzusuchen. So gibt es jetzt auch wieder eine neue Entwicklung, bekannt oder beziehungsweise noch nicht so richtig bekannt, vielleicht jetzt demnächst ein bisschen bekannter, hoffen wir, ist das Ganze unter dem Schlagwort Telekom-Paket.
Was ist das? Ja, das Telekom-Paket ist die zukünftige europäische Rahmengesetzgebung für den kompletten Telekommunikationsbereich. Wenn man sich Telekommunikation genauer anschaut, dann fällt darunter das komplette Internet. Das wird seit über einem Jahr auf europäischer Ebene diskutiert und besteht aus vier verschiedenen Richtlinien, die zusammen mit einer Empfehlung noch den ganzen Rahmen vorgeben. Und das sind die unterschiedlichen Richtlinien. Es gibt eine Rahmenrichtlinie, die gibt den Rahmen vor, die sagt, wie diese ganzen Richtlinien miteinander interagieren. Es gibt eine Richtlinie zur Einrichtung einer europäischen Regulierungsbehörde. Das hat aber keinen Richtlinienstatus mehr. Da haben sich eher geeinigt, dass die nationalen Regulierungsbehörden mal einen Arbeitskreis oder ein bisschen mehr als einen Arbeitskreis bilden. Also eher eine Koordination als eine europäische Regulierungsbehörde.
Also so wie die RekTP.
Genau, aber eher eine verbesserte Koordination europäischen RekTPs als eine eigene RekTP auf EU-Ebene zu schaffen. Aber das war auch eine lange Diskussion. Dann gibt es die sogenannte Universaldienstrichtlinie. Das ist am ehesten vergleichbar mit unserem Telekommunikationsgesetz, was wir in Deutschland, TKG, vor zwei oder drei Jahren reformiert haben. Aber andere Länder haben das noch nicht. In Europa ist ja immer eine Harmonisierung. Und dann gibt es die Datenschutzrichtlinie, die ePrivacy-Richtlinie. Und es gibt noch eine Empfehlung an die Kommission für die digitale Dividende. Da geht es eher darum, was machen wir jetzt eigentlich mit den ganzen Spektren? Die da frei werden. Also die ganzen Frequenzbänder. Wie gehen wir damit um? Also verkaufen wir die alle in die Wirtschaft oder machen wir da irgendwie andere Dinge mit? Und das zusammen ergibt halt das Telekom-Paket.
Das klingt ja jetzt erstmal alles nicht so schlimm.
Ja, das klingt also erstmal nicht so schlimm. Dazu hat man das Video so auf EU-Ebene. Also erstmal macht die EU-Kommission einen Vorschlag. Dann geht es halt darüber. Dann diskutieren quasi parallel die EU-Staaten im EU-Rat darüber miteinander. Und das EU-Parlament, das die Staaten miteinander diskutieren, das ist meistens relativ intransparent. Und die gaspern dann irgendwas miteinander aus. Das EU-Parlament ist ein bisschen spannender, weil da viel mehr Menschen mitmischen. Und weil da viele Menschen mitmischen, hat man halt auch dann diese vier verschiedenen Richtlinien auf vier verschiedene Ausschüsse verteilt. Und dass halt jeder irgendwie mal so einen kleinen Teil mitdiskutieren kann. Und das wird halt jetzt da im Industrieausschuss und im Bürgerrechtsausschuss und im Verbraucher- und Binnenmarktsausschuss. Und in den unterschiedlichsten Ausschüssen werden halt unterschiedlichste Bestandteile irgendwie diskutiert. Und dann zum Schluss setzt man das alles zusammen in einer letzten Abstimmung. Die wird am 22. September vermutlich stattfinden. Und dann hat zumindest das EU-Parlament etwas beschlossen, was, wie wir es von der Vorratsansprechung und Softwarepatenten kennen, dann nochmal gemeinsam, also da muss man nochmal einen gemeinsamen Standpunkt mit dem EU-Rat finden. Also es ist dann vergleichbar mit einem Kompromissprozess zwischen Bundesrat und Bundestag. Und dann ist so eine Richtlinie durch. Oder so ein Richtlinienpaket. Dann müssen die Länder im Rahmen der Harmonisierung an die nationale Gesetzgebung anpassen. Aber dann hat man halt meistens kaum noch Gestaltungsspielraum.
Wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung sozusagen.
Ja, genau, das ist EU.
So, was ist denn das Gute an diesem Telekom-Paket?
Das Gute an diesem Telekom-Paket ist, dass man halt mal einen europäischen Rahmen schafft für Telekommunikation. Also Europa ist ja auch immer viel Harmonisierung. Harmonisierung muss nicht immer schlecht sein. Ist ja auch was Gutes, wenn wir halt zum Beispiel bei Roaminggebühren werden auch mit geregelt, dass man halt irgendwie, wenn man in andere Länder reist, dass man da nicht irgendwie vom eigenen Telekommunikationsprovider, also Handy-Provider in der Regel, irgendwie komplett ausgenommen wird, wenn man dann aus Italien zurück nach Deutschland telefoniert.
Oder das Internet benutzt.
Genau, kennt sehr. Also dass man da halt quasi mal irgendwie so, da will man eine Staffelung hinbekommen und dann, ja, dass man halt einfach mal irgendwie Druck ausübt und reguliert, halt einfach sagt, hey, Telekommunikationsunternehmen, ihr kriegt es offensichtlich nicht hin. Wir vertreten jetzt mal quasi den Willen der Bürger und stärken die Verbraucherrechte. Und dieses ganze Paket ist eigentlich auch gemacht worden mit dem Ziel, irgendwie Verbraucherrechte zu stärken. Also das ist ja erstmal was Schönes und Gutes. Und im Sinne von allen. Ja, und bei so Sachen wie halt Roaminggebühren und so weiter, was halt auch immer in den Medien irgendwie als hey, das Ganze ist doch ganz toll und so weiter dargestellt wird, ja, ist es auch. Hat aber ein paar Macken.
Also scharfe Grasen, irgendwie auf den grünen Weiden, Schäfchenwolken am Horizont, alles wird gut.
Ja, also wenn man halt die EU-Kommission irgendwie hört, dann ist alles super. Das Problem an dieser ganzen Sache ist, wenn verschiedenste Ausschüsse an verschiedensten Richtlinien irgendwie zusammenwerkeln, die zum Schluss irgendwie, also jeder baut so seinen eigenen Teil vom Puzzle zusammen und zum Schluss legt man das zu einem riesigen Puzzle zusammen, dann haben halt wenige Leute irgendwie einen Überblick, wie sieht zum Schluss irgendwie das ganze Puzzle aus, was halt das im Endeffekt ergibt.
Was nicht nur ein europäisches Problem ist, sondern eigentlich auf jedem Level ist. Ich meine, auch im Bundestag gibt es Gesetze, Pakete, die dann immer wieder solche...
Genau, noch schlimmer ist es, wenn du halt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Kompromissvorschläge irgendwie machst und so, ja, berühmte Beispiele, Gesundheitsreform, dann zum Schluss hat man eigentlich überhaupt nichts mehr abgestimmt oder sonst irgendwie, und das sind die ganzen Konzepte, die haben sich mittlerweile untereinander dann durch Kompromisse irgendwie so zusammengetan, dass du halt Salz und Pfeffer zusammentust und es kommt nichts Gutes dabei herum. Also, ja, das ist das Problem. Und bei dem Telekom-Paket, was halt, wie gesagt, irgendwie zur Stärkung von Verbraucherrechten irgendwie initiiert worden ist, hatte man halt irgendwann das Problem, also das wird halt in Ausschüssen diskutiert, so ein Ausschuss wie der Verbraucher- und Binnenmarksausschuss, der hat dann wiederum im EU-Parlament Schattenberichterstatter, das heißt, jede Fraktion stellt einen Schattenberichterstatter für eine Richtlinie in einem Ausschuss ab. Und dann bist du der Verantwortliche für diese Richtlinie in diesem Ausschuss.
Schattenberichterstatter.
Ja, so nennt man das. Also meistens gibt es einen richtigen Berichterstatter, das ist dann derjenige, dessen Name zum Schluss unter so einer Richtlinie steht. Das ist halt so quasi der Hauptkoordinator. Dann gibt es noch wiederum von Vertretern der ganzen Fraktion Schattenberichterstatter. Das sind halt sozusagen, die bilden zusammen diesen Vorstand und dealen dann untereinander aus. Ja, und der ganze Rest, der ist halt mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt, weil irgendwie, die meisten sind irgendwo Schattenberichterstatter in irgendwelchen Ausschüssen und irgendwelchen Richtlinien und halt immer einen Experten für irgendwas irgendwo drin. Naja, und beim Telekom-Paket war halt das Hauptproblem, dass halt irgendwann lagen vor den Ausschuss-Abstimmungen, das war, muss ich auch nochmal kurz gucken, wann war das jetzt überhaupt, wie lange ist das jetzt schon her? Im Juni, Anfang Juli. Juli, Juli, Juli. Ja, das war Ende Juli. Ende Juni war auf einmal ein Zeitpunkt erreicht, da lagen auf einmal im Industrieausschuss 800 Änderungsvorschläge, sogenannte Amendments auf dem Tisch. Im Binnenmarktsausschuss 300, wenn ich das jetzt nicht genau anders herum verwechsel, auf jeden Fall, aber Unmengen an Änderungsanträgen. Also jeder Abgeordnete, der in irgendeinem Ausschuss drin sitzt, und meistens die Schattenberichterstatter, die können da Änderungsanträge reingehen. Und dann hat man halt das Problem, die meisten wissen eh schon nicht, worum es überhaupt geht, weil man ist halt grad nicht der Schattenberichterstatter, man muss aber in einer Abstimmung teilnehmen, und dann hat man da echt so ein ganzes Papierwerk an Änderungsanträgen. Und wenn jetzt nicht grad irgendwie der Schattenberichterstatter und sein Mitarbeiter ein heller Kopf sind und halt einfach das alles mal durchgelesen haben und das mit den anderen Puzzlen zusammen abgeglichen haben, hast du halt ein Problem. Und es gab halt verschiedene Leute auf internationaler, also europäischer Ebene, namentlich muss man da Monika Horten, britische Politologin erwähnen, die macht gerade glaube ich gerade ihre Dissertationen in Politikwissenschaften über das Telekom-Paket, die sich halt mal zu den ganzen Puzzlestücken angeschaut hat und feststand, dass einige von diesen Amendments, die von diesen Berichterstattern und von einigen Schattenberichterstattern favorisiert worden sind, also diese Änderungsanträge, dass die halt mehr oder weniger das sind, was die Musikindustrie seit einem Jahr fordert. Und dass man die halt in eine Richtlinie, also quasi eher das Gegenteil einbaut, als Verbraucherrechte zu stärken. Und das sind die unterschiedlichsten Änderungsanträgen drin gewesen. Und die wären halt beinahe durchgekommen, weil es gab eigentlich gar keine Kritik an diesem ganzen System. Alle waren echt so, sie fühlen sich alle ganz gut dabei und haben das ja bald hinter sich und können ja endlich mal abstimmen. Bis es auf einmal eine europäische Kampagne dagegen gab, die von Digital Rights Organisationen und Aktivisten geführt wurde und die halt eine Woche vor diesen Ausschussabstimmungen, man weiß ja, es geht ja auch zeitlich teilweise gar nicht früher, weil du hast immer erst kurz vorher, weißt du halt alles, was an Änderungsanträgen da ist und du setzt das halt zusammen und siehst aber dieses ganze Bild und denkst dir, scheiße, wir haben ein Problem so. Dann haben wir halt massiv mobilisiert. Das war dann vor allen Dingen La Quadrature du Net, eine französische Aktivisten-Organisation. Dann Open Rights Group aus Großbritannien. Und wir von netzpolitik.org und haben einfach irgendwie gesagt, hey, wir sagen jetzt mal, das was ihr da irgendwie abstimmen wollt, das hat die und die und die Probleme. Und wir haben halt alle, die wir erreichen konnten, aufgefordert, wendet euch an eure Abgeordneten, nutzt alle möglichen Kommunikationskanäle und weist sie darauf hin, dass sie mal irgendwie darauf achten sollen, was sie da überhaupt tun. Und dass sie gefälligst irgendwie auch für ein freies und offenes Internet abstimmen sollen. Und das hat erst mal im Vorfeld, so die Woche vor den Ausschusssitzungen, eine ganze Menge Mobilisierung erreicht, dass eine ganze Menge Menschen sich auf den verschiedensten Kanälen an die Politik gewandt haben. Die Medien haben auch mal wieder relativ kaum mitgespielt, außer den üblichen Gedechnungen wie High-Sea-Future-Zonen und so weiter. Aber wie mir von verschiedenen Mitarbeitern und Abgeordneten erzählt worden ist, wir haben da teilweise deren Kommunikation lahmgelegt. Weil die ganze Zeit riefen irgendwelche Leute an oder schickten E-Mails oder schickten Faxe und so weiter und die konnten das nicht mehr hören. Das kannten wir von einer Software-Patente-Debatte. Einfach massenmobilisieren und die echt darauf aufmerksam machen. Und wir haben einen guten Zeitpunkt, ein Jahr vor der Bundestagswahl. Jetzt sind die auch ein bisschen bewusster im Umgang mit den Bürgern, weil sie wollen ja wieder irgendwie gefehlt werden. Und das führt halt dazu, dass zumindest die Hardcore-Positionen abgelehnt worden sind. Sie haben sich auf eine Kompromisslinie geeinigt in den Ausschüssen, wo wir immer noch der Meinung sind, naja, wenn ihr Verbraucherrechte stacken wollt, dann sind da immer noch genug Sachen drin. Und wir fordern euch eigentlich auf, bei der Endabstimmung am 22. September für ein bürgerrechts- und verbraucherschutzfreundliches Telekom-Paket abzustimmen und für ein freies und offenes Internet. Und nicht für die Kompromisslinie, weil das eigentlich auch der halbe Forderungskatalog der Musikindustrie und Filmindustrie ist und eigentlich ein lauter Fallstrecke enthält, wo man halt wiederum über andere Richtlinien, man muss ja immer Richtlinien zusammensetzen und so weiter, halt wiederum Verbraucherrechte abgebaut werden.
Gut, dann werden wir nochmal konkret. Was sind denn das für schlimme Dinge, die da jetzt drin sind, den Widerstand sozusagen?
Es sind Sachen, am berühmtesten ist halt die Idee der Musikindustrie, also der internationale Verband der Musikindustrie hat vor eineinhalb Jahren Positionspapier vorgelegt, der Three Strikes and You Are Out Strategie. Also man möchte Fallsharing effektiver dadurch bekämpfen, da stellt man sich so ein Modell vor. Man schickt halt oder die Staaten schicken, ob durch eine Behörde oder über die Provider selbst irgendwie Warnhinweise an die Internetnutzer, wenn sie Fallsharing gemacht haben. Und nach dem dritten Mal wird einem das Internet zensiert. Also Three Strikes and You Are Out. Irgendwie ist das Internet weg. Bisher halt ausgeschlossen von der digitalen Gesellschaft. Und das sehen die halt. Das ist halt in den Augen von verschiedenen Politikern. Das ist halt schon ein Ding wie, nimmt man ihnen halt mal den Führerschein für Kiffen ab, dann werden sie das schon lernen. Das ist halt eine Sache, die ist in den USA abends das Versuch. Dort ist es nicht so ganz geklappt so. Dann sind sie in der Frankreich, da war gerade Sir Sarkozy an die Macht gekommen und der hat ja bekanntlich verschiedene einflussreiche Medienfreunde und das war halt da sofort irgendwie, ging das dann in die Diskussion rein. Und die diskutieren immer noch, weil es immer noch nicht so ganz klar, ob das jetzt verfassungskonform ist oder nicht.
Die wollen durchsetzen, dass wenn man als Einzelperson identifiziert wird, dass man irgendwas geschert hat, dass einem dann sozusagen als Person Zugang zum Netz verboten wird.
Ja, also erst beim dritten Mal, nach dem Motto, erste Mal falsch sharing bei erwischt, kriegst du Verwarnung. Beim zweiten Mal kriegst du noch mal eine Verwarnung. Und beim dritten Mal innerhalb von sechs Monaten oder zwölf Monaten ist das Internet weg.
Aber nicht mein DSL-Anschluss wird abgeknipft, sondern ich darf nirgendswo mehr das Internet benutzen.
Dein DSL-Anschluss wird abgeknipft.
Wenn ich dann einen neuen beantrage?
Ja, die Ausgestaltungsmöglichkeiten ist total unklar. Da kann auch jeder irgendwo hingehen. Aber es ist erst mal die Grundfrage. Ist das überhaupt gerechtfertigt? Ist das verhältnismäßig? Ist das überhaupt der richtige Weg, mit dem Urheberrecht im digitalen Zeitalter uns umzugehen?
Ich frage mich, was ist mit den anderen Leuten in meinem Haushalt? Was ist in der WG?
Es sind lauter ungeklärte Fragen. In Frankreich wollen sie eine Behörde dafür einrichten. Die soll dann von der Musikindustrie, ich meine die Musikindustrie hat in Deutschland ihre Promedia GmbH, in Hamburg sitzen die, schauen die ganze Zeit, welche IP-Adressen falsch machen für bestimmte Files und schicken dann Abmahnungen. Zum Glück werden ja gerade über die Staatsanwaltschaften ein bisschen abgeblockt, aber es ist der Weg. Die stellen sich vor, sie sitzen da weiterhin als private Sheriffs und schicken dann irgendwie eine IP-Adresse an den Provider. Der Provider soll dann verpflichtet von der Politik zur Kooperation die IP-Adressen der eigenen Kunden, die den Provider finanzieren, verwahren und dann irgendwie abklemmen.
Internetprovider sollen sozusagen ihre eigenen Kunden kündigen dürfen?
Ja, nicht kündigen. Das ist ja noch die Frage, ob man kündigt oder das Geld weiter einzieht.
Nein, nein, ich habe versucht, das war ein schlechtes Bild. Sie sollen sich sozusagen ihre eigenen Kunden entledigen, weil die Kunden das Internet kündigen.
Genau, das ist halt immer noch die Frage. Also die Three Strikes and You're Out. Die Hardcore-Lösung ist halt, also Frankreich ist auch hingegangen, die haben gerade Rat zur Präsidentschaft und wollten das Ganze nur noch für EU-Ebene ausweiten. Und in England sind die auch ziemlich weit gekommen mit der Musikindustrie. In Deutschland ist es noch unklar. In Deutschland gab es ja den Fall, wir hatten einen Tag des Geistigen Eigentums, ich glaube, 26. April, da hat die Musikindustrie eigentlich PR-technisch ganz schön klug in verschiedenen großen Zeitungen ganzseitige Anzeigen gekauft und einen offenen Brief von 200 Künstlern von Gerönemeyer bis Klaus und Klaus unterschreiben lassen, dass sie jetzt ähnliche Maßnahmen wie in Frankreich fordern. Die wir, unser Kulturstaatsminister und unsere Bundeskanzlerin haben auch sofort gesagt, ja, müssen wir machen, finden wir toll. Und im Endeffekt haben die gefordert, oder Klaus und Klaus hat gefordert, dass sie das Internet weggenommen werden sollen, wenn du Tauschpüren nutzt. Also wie das halt so ist, man weiß halt nicht, selbst in Frankreich ist es noch unglaublich, so konform ist mit deren Verfassung, also macht man es auf EU-Ebene, weil da hat man sofort besser, weil dann kann man sofort harmonisch irgendwie...
Da gibt es zwar erstmal gar keine Verfassung.
Ja, genau, das ist ein anderes Problem, aber da kann man das dann erstmal bestimmen, da weiß EKA genau, worum es geht und dann kann man es wieder runterbrechen. Und das war halt und ist immer noch so der Weg. Ja, also in den EU-Ausschusssitzungen im Parlament sind halt, sagen wir mal, die Hardcore-Anträge erstmal rausgenommen worden. Jetzt sind in den Kompromissanträgen immer noch so Sachen drin, die halt so von Kooperation zwischen Providern und Musikindustrie, also EU- oder Inhalteanbietern irgendwie reden, wo man sich fragt, was ist das für überhaupt, was soll das für eine Kooperation sein? Im Endeffekt, Provider waren und sollen eigentlich immer noch irgendwie neutral sein. Die sollen eigentlich nur dafür zuständig sein, mir einen Internetzugang bereitzustellen und einfach die Daten dadurch zu jagen. Die sollen überhaupt gar nicht schauen, was da für Daten langgehen. Ich will ja auch nicht, dass die Deutsche Telekom irgendwie über unseren Telefonanschlüssen mal irgendwie abchecken. Manche macht es ja anscheinend, was da Leute miteinander kommunizieren, was sie da bereden. Und so soll das halt auch nicht im Internet passieren.
Es ist ungefähr so, als ob Taxifahrer jetzt dazu angehalten werden, doch mal zu überprüfen, aus welchen Motivationen die Leute zum Flughafen fahren. Und wenn das irgendwie jemanden nicht passt, dann sie irgendwie rausschmeißen und nicht zum Flughafen fahren.
Also es waren da teilweise Sachen dabei, wo man sich dachte, ihr redet hier die ganze Zeit von chinesischer Internetzensur und ihr wollt hier tatsächlich irgendwelche Zensurinfrastrukturen in Europa aufbauen, damit man irgendwie...
Na ja, Zensur in dem Sinne ist es ja nicht, oder?
Urheberrechtlich geschützte Werke, also Filter, die wollten die Provider verpflichten, dass sie Filter einbauen. Dass sie Filter einbauen, wo man halt dann irgendwie verhindert, dass der neueste Madonna-Song oder so runtergeladen wird und halt einfach mal rauszensiert.
Was technisch überhaupt nicht durchsetzbar ist.
Na ja, ist technisch nicht durchsetzbar. Ich meine, es gibt halt große IT-Unternehmen, die haben große leistungsfähige Router und die verkaufen die ja auch in andere Staaten und verkaufen die auch in Europa und in den USA mit. Hey, mach die Packet-Inspection. Du schaffst 4x10 Gigabit in Echtzeit und sonstwie und dann könnt ihr den ganzen Verkehr überwachen. Und dann kannst du halt dann auch irgendwie Filter einbauen und so weiter. Und was die jetzt in der Politik berehen, das wird in drei Jahren umgesetzt und dann hast du noch viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Na gut, aber die Falsch-Sharing-Szene geht ja nun auch in zunehmendem Maße dazu über, alles zu verschlüsseln. Das ist eigentlich...
Ja, also das ist ein Wettrüsten, was nicht gewonnen werden kann. Aber abgesehen, das ist halt total unverhältnismäßig. Das ist ein Eingriff in die Netzneutralität. Wo kommen wir überhaupt hin?
Eingriff in die Netzneutralität, interessanter Stichpunkt. Netzneutralität... Müssen wir im Prinzip nochmal drüber reden, oder können wir das mal kurz einwerfen? Es gibt ja keine. Gibt es irgendeine europäische Richtlinie, oder ist da vielleicht in dieser Richtlinie mit drin, in diesem Telekom-Paket, wovon sowas überhaupt mal gesprochen wird? Weil bisher ist das Ganze nur ein Buzzword. Dass es eine Diskussion in den USA geführt wird. Mir ist nicht bewusst, dass es irgendein Gesetz gibt, oder irgendeine nennenswerte politische Diskussion, wo das überhaupt mal anerkannt wird, oder festgeschrieben wird, oder überhaupt irgendjemand versucht das durchzusetzen.
Nee, gibt es tatsächlich nicht. Aber vielleicht sollte man erstmal kurz erklären, wo kommt dieser Begriff eigentlich her, und wo wurde er geprägt. Das Internet selbst ist als Ökosystem eigentlich so groß geworden, dass halt alle Datenpakete gleich behandelt worden sind. Also es gab keine Unterscheidung in gute Inhalte, in schlechte Inhalte, in privilegierte Inhalte, oder sonst irgendwie Inhalte. Da mögen jetzt gewisse Admins sagen, in ihrem Netzwerk funktioniert das anders. Sie priorisieren da bestimmte Datenpakete und sonst wie. Aber das Internet ist eigentlich groß geworden, dass jeder dieselben Zugangschancen hatte, dass nicht die großen Reichen einfach die ganzen Ressourcen hatten und die fetten Autobahnen irgendwie befahren konnten für ihre Kunden. Und die ganzen kleinen, die hatten dann irgendwie die Nebenwege zu fahren. Also es konnten 16-jährige Hotmail oder sonst irgendwie gründen und großen machen oder ICQ oder YouTube und diese Google, diese ganzen Beispiele, wo man halt einfach die Chance hat, irgendwie junge kreative Leute bauen was und haben dieselbe Chance quasi wie andere. Oder wir können unsere Blogs und unsere Podcasts ins Netz setzen und die Inhalte werden genauso gleich behandelt.
Wie die nicht existenten Aufzeichnungen des Bundestages.
Genau, aber in den USA gibt es eine leicht andere Reparaturunde um die Netzneutralität. Da gibt es eigentlich den Kampf der alten Telcos gegen halt diese großen Unternehmen wie Google und Co. Also da ist eigentlich so die Grundfrage, die die Telcos stellen. Hey, also uns gehören hier die ganzen Infrastrukturen, wir haben hier die ganzen Kabel hingelegt, also jetzt kommt hier Google hin und macht uns einfach Konkurrenz. Dann wollen wir halt von Google Geld haben, weil die nutzen halt unsere Infrastrukturen. In den USA tobt seit zwei oder drei Jahren der Kampf darum, dass man die Netzneutralität festschreibt, per Gesetz, um halt den Telcos zu verbieten, da einfach eine Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft einzuführen. Die wollen natürlich diese ganzen Triple-Play-Angebote und sonst irgendwie, die wollen halt, Telekom würde das wahrscheinlich auch am liebsten wollen, ihre eigenen Sachen, ihre Fernsehkanäle und Internet und alles Mögliche privilegiert für ihre eigenen Kunden und wer mehr zahlt, kriegt mehr Zugang verkaufen. Und dessen Datenpakete werden halt irgendwie priorisiert und die anderen, die halt nicht zahlen, die werden halt ein bisschen zurückgestellt. Aber in den USA gibt es tatsächlich diese Debatte darum. Das ist jetzt auch irgendwie vor allen Dingen im aktuellen US-Wahlkampf ist das eine ziemliche Polarisierung. Die Demokraten scheinen sich jetzt gerade alle unter Obama auf Netzneutralität eingeschossen zu haben. Die Republikaner sind in der Regel eher telco-freundlich. Ich meine, wie Telcos finanzieren halt deren Urlaub und Kampagnen und so weiter. In Europa haben wir das so, auch leider nicht so. In Europa wird die Debatte um Netzneutralität eher irgendwie leicht anders geführt. Bei uns geht halt immer alles um Urheberrecht. Also da geht es halt eher darum, ob man jetzt irgendwie mal die Beton-Ports einfach mal wegfiltert oder wegzensiert, damit die Jugend da nicht irgendwie schädliche Inhalte drüber kopiert und irgendwie in Gefahr läuft, irgendwie Urheberrechtsüberletzungen begehen zu können. Aber es gibt noch keine Initiative, die jetzt sagt, wir brauchen auch in Europa eine Gesetzgebung, um Netzneutralität zu gewährleisten. Die einen Experten sagen, wir brauchen das, die anderen Experten sagen, besser nicht anfangen, weil wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie versuchen, dann geht das alles nach hinten los und die Telkos gewinnen. Aber Fakt ist eigentlich aus der Geschichte des Internets, dass es was Sinnvolles ist, diese Netzneutralität. Sie ermöglicht Innovation, sie ermöglicht Teilhabe und das ist eine demokratische Sache. Der gleichberechtigte Zugang zu den Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen. Und das sollten wir jetzt nicht leichtwertig aufgrund von gewissen einseitigen wirtschaftlichen Interessen irgendwie aufgeben, weil das würde halt die ganze Innovationskultur irgendwie des Internets behindern und das würde eine massive Auswirkung auf eine digitale Gesellschaft haben.
Hm, klar. Zurück zu diesem Telekom-Paket. Also ist denn das jetzt der einzige wirkliche... Also ist das jetzt sozusagen das, worüber du dich primär aufregst, dass die Musikindustrie dort hineinwischt, oder sagen wir mal die Copyright-Gesetzgebung und Strafverfahren interessierten Gruppen?
Ja, also sagen wir mal, es ist normalerweise so, dass wir leben in einer Demokratie und Interessenverbände können sich auch gerne da einmischen. Ich kritisiere an der EU, ich kritisiere an unserer Bundesregierung, dass sie eigentlich mehr oder weniger einseitig seit zig Jahren die Interessen der Verwerter immer stärker berücksichtigt. Und das ist ja ein Wettrüsten, was da stattfindet, wo immer weiter Verbraucher und Bürgerrechte geschleift werden. Und es bringt keine nachhaltige Antwort. Und andere Positionen spielen eigentlich nie eine Rolle. Und da kann man denen dann schon vorwerfen, dass sie einseitig quasi von particularen Wirtschaftsinteressen, die also particulare Wirtschaftsinteressen vertreten. Das ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger die allgemeine Leitlinie europäischer Wirtschaftspolitik ist. Und ja, auch wenn sie jetzt diese Filter leicht abgeschwächt haben und jetzt in dem Kompromissantrag, den sie beschlossen haben, schreiben sie auch davon, naja gut, wir machen jetzt auf EU-Ebene, machen wir jetzt nichts so, wir schreiben jetzt keine Filter vor, aber die Nationalstaaten dürfen was machen. Und es gibt halt noch andere Sachen, dass man halt, also da muss man halt in die Textexegese der Texte reingehen, die sprechen halt die ganze Zeit von lawful content, gesetzmäßiger Content, der gefördert werden soll. Da sträumen sich mir natürlich sämtliche Nackenhaare, weil es gibt weder eine Definition, was lawful, also gesetzmäßiger Content ist, noch gibt es eine Gegendefinition, okay, lawful-mäßiger Content soll gefördert werden. Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Es gibt anscheinend dann auch unlawful-Content. Wie findet man raus, das ist was unlawful-Content und was lawful-Content ist? Wer definiert das überhaupt, was lawful-Content ist? Und was wollt ihr überhaupt damit machen? Und das ist halt den wenigsten da auf EU-Ebene bewusst, dass sie da einfach mal irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Wörtern rumjonglieren, die halt so eine große Interpretationsweite haben. Dass du da eigentlich alles danach später reinsetzen kannst als Schnittstelle, so ja, zack, ja, habt ihr doch beschlossen und wir brauchen jetzt dann doch Filter, um halt gegen Lawful Content umzugehen. Dann gibt es noch so andere Sachen, wie jetzt sollen dann nur noch irgendwie die Provider ihre Kunden über Lawful Content und so weiter dann auch aufklären, wo die EU-Kommission, also unsere, die erklärt dann, ja, eigentlich ist damit gemeint, dass halt die Provider irgendwie mal irgendwie sagen sollen oder ihren Kunden sagen sollen, dass Tauschbörsen jetzt verboten sind oder die Nutzung von den meisten, also die meisten Anwendungsnutzung von Tauschbörsen. Dann sagen aber die anderen so, vor allem die Musikindustrie meint, ja, also das haben wir eigentlich nicht so gemeint. Wenn man sich das mal so wirklich durchlässt, dann ist halt schon gemeint, ihr müsst den Warnbrief schicken und so weiter. Und es gibt halt in England gerade halt die... Das hatten wir eben, Three Strikes and You're Out, du machst falsch her. In Großbritannien ist es jetzt zum Beispiel so, sie wollten halt auch die Frankreich-Linie machen mit zweimal Warnbriefe, dann Internet-Zensur. Jetzt machen sie erst mal nur die Warnbriefe über eine Übergangsfrist. Sie machen so eine Testphase, was aber genauso heißen kann, wenn die Testphase abgelaufen ist, die haben alle Warnbriefe bekommen, aber die Kiddies halten sich halt nicht dran, machen weiter falsch her und dann schatzt da jetzt dann wieder die nächste Eskalationsstufe ein. Ich meine, über rechts haben wir ja seit zehn Jahren nur weitere Eskalationsstufen und das Problem wird einfach nicht gelöst, weil vielleicht sind es die falschen Lösungsansätze. Aber europäische Politik sagt dann, noch härter draufschlagen. Und die Jugend wird halt irgendwann mal lernen.
Ja, das ist eher die Frage, ob die Alten irgendwann noch mal lernen. Du hast gesagt, dass in diesen Richtlinien gibt es auch eine Datenschutzrichtlinie, oder E-Privacy, das klingt ja auch erstmal ganz gut. Ist da was Brauchbares drin?
Ja, da sind eine Menge brauchbare Sachen drin. Da gibt es ja auch irgendwie Harmonisierung von Datenschutzrechten in Deutschland. Da gibt es eigentlich so im Großen und Ganzen so in dieser ganzen Diskussion einen riesigen Streit- und Konfliktpunkt, der noch nicht so wirklich gelöst ist. Nämlich die Frage, sind IP-Adressen jetzt personenbezogene Daten oder nicht? Das ist halt eine sehr spannende Frage. Und da treffen tatsächlich riesige wirtschaftliche Interessen von, auch größtenteils US-Unternehmen wie Google und Co., auf europäische Datenschützer. Da sagen natürlich die Datenschützer, na klar, eine IP-Adresse ist eine personenbezogene Information und die muss halt dann unter Datenschutzrichtlinien irgendwie geschützt werden. Und die Google sagt halt, so hinter dem Hintergrund, dass wenn eine IP-Adresse halt personenbezogene Daten sind, dann können die halt nicht mehr so viel mit den Informationen anstellen, wie ihre ganzen Zugang-Fragen. Das ist es natürlich nicht. Und da treffen natürlich auch irgendwie die unterschiedlichen Auslegungen aufeinander, ob man jetzt eher wirtschaftsliberal ist, und dann halt mal irgendwie gegen den Datenschutz ist, aber man ist ja liberal und sonst, das sind manchmal bei den Liberalen ein bisschen schizophren, oder ob man jetzt irgendwie stark auf Bürgerrechte und Datenschutz irgendwie wertlegt. Und das ist halt auch immer noch so ein Punkt, wo halt noch nicht ganz klar ist, was ist am Ende die Abstimmung.
Was sind denn da jetzt die nächsten Schritte bei diesem Telekom-Paket? Also wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, es gab erst mal diese ganze Bewegung, da ist jetzt ein Jahr lang dran rumgeschraubt worden, dann gab es den Weg zur Abstimmung, zu dem Zeitpunkt war das schon verschmutzt worden, durch diese ganzen Warnbriefe, Falsch-Sharing-Maßnahmen, Internet-Abschaltungen, Ideen, das wurde dann verhindert durch den Protest, was war denn das für eine Abstimmung? War das eine Vorabstimmung oder eine erste Lesung? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also die Ausschüsse diskutieren die einzelnen Richtlinien und da sind teilweise auch zwei, drei Ausschüsse an einer Richtlinie beteiligt oder an mehreren, aber es gibt einen sozusagen, der stimmt dann federführend ab. Das ist normal, ne?
Ist ja nachvollziehbar. Ich meine, ich würde als Informatikexperte dann auch nicht unbedingt gerade über Politereifragen entscheiden wollen.
Politik ist halt tierisch komplex, da muss halt Arbeitsteilung machen, hat halt vor Nachteile. Auf jeden Fall sind die jetzt gerade alle in Sommerpause. Wir haben da ja einen Monat Sommerferien und so weiter.
Hätte man auch gescannt. Also ihr wollt ja nochmal kurz, dieser Einfluss, den ihr ausgeübt habt, der hat dann genau konkret was bewirkt? Der Ausschuss, der zuständig war für diese Einrichtlinie, das nicht so verabschiedet hat, sondern wie?
Genau, also sagen wir mal, es gab Hardcore-Änderungsanträge, die halt quasi so die reine Lehre der Musikindustrie und Filmindustrie irgendwie vertreten haben, die sind ein bisschen rausgekickt worden. Und sie haben sich auf Änderungsanträge oder Kompromissvorschläge geeinigt, die jetzt nicht mehr ganz so stark sind, aber die immer noch in die Richtung gehen und die unserer Meinung nach immer noch genug Fallstrecke irgendwie beinhalten. Deswegen sind wir auch dagegen, dass diese Kompromisslinie zum Schluss vom EU-Parlament abgestimmt wird. Dieser ganze Protest hat erreicht, dass die Hardcore-Linie nicht durchgekommen ist. Es ist eine Kompromisslinie durchgekommen.
Was besagt denn diese Kompromisslinie konkret?
Da habe ich ja schon mal ein paar Sachen gesagt. Man fängt jetzt nicht an, auf EU-Ebene Filter zu fordern, sondern das können die Nationalstaaten machen.
Also es wird eigentlich nur abgeschoben, nach dem Motto, wir beschließen das jetzt mal nicht, aber wir sagen auch nicht, dass es nicht stattfinden darf.
Genau, also es wäre halt eigentlich, wie man könnte auch sagen, ja, es darf halt nicht stattfinden. Ich meine, man beschließt im EU-Parlament auch immer tolle irgendwie Resolutionen, dass Internet sind nur in China schlecht ist und free flow of information ganz toll ist. Also das wäre eine Möglichkeit. Andere Sachen sind halt, dass da immer noch so Wörter drin sind, was man halt in diesem Lauf voll Content macht, wie ich gerade schon beschrieben habe und so weiter. Also im Endeffekt, die haben da eine Kompromisslinie abgestimmt. Und das kommt jetzt nach der Sommerpause. Gibt es wahrscheinlich am 2. September nochmal irgendwie weitere Beratungen, weil dann gucken sie nochmal, ob sie jetzt damit, ob das okay ist, dass es so am ehesten vergleichbar mit einer ersten Lesung, was da so stattfindet, aber wahrscheinlich auch in den Ausschusssitzungen. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau.
2. September, 2008, wir müssen mal die Jahreszahl sagen, weil dieser Podcast wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört. Und von daher war es ein Frevel, dass sie das am Anfang nicht angesagt haben.
Am 25. August sind die Abgeordneten in der Regel dann wieder aus dem Urlaub zurück, weil dann ist die offizielle Sommerpause im EU-Parlament beendet.
Das ist von heute zwei Wochen.
Das sind zwei Wochen. Da sind eigentlich die Planungen, dass wir da mit verschiedensten Aktivisten nach Brüssel fahren, Notfalls unsere Schlafsäcke mitnehmen und uns eine Woche einquartieren und einfach mal rumlaufen durchs EU-Parlament wie damals beim Softwarepatenten und einfach mal überall anklopfen und unsere Gesprächsbereitschaft anbieten und das zu erklären.
Kann man da einfach so rein ins EU-Parlament? Ja, nicht wirklich.
Aber wenn du Abgeordnete oder Mitarbeiter kennst, dann kriegst du halt so eine Karte und dann holst du dir halt ein Wochenticket und dann kannst du da rein und rauslaufen. Du darfst halt keinen Scheiß bauen. Bei einem Software-Patent haben wir festgestellt, du darfst halt keine T-Shirts mit politischer Willensäußerung getragen. Dann wirst du sofort rausgeschmissen oder musst dann mit einem nackten Oberkörper rumlaufen.
Das heißt, ich starr die 2.0-T-Shirts, die müssen zu Hause bleiben.
Ja, das ist auch nicht so ganz gut. Aber was halt erstmal diese ganze Mobilisierung gebracht hat, ist, dass die Abgeordneten festgestellt haben, sie müssten sich damit mal beschäftigen. Also es gibt so verschiedenste Aussagen von Abgeordneten, die dann von Heise oder Futureson angequatscht worden sind. Und die halt sagen, ja, es ist ja ganz praktisch, dass uns die Bürger mal darauf aufmerksam gemacht haben, dass es da wohl irgendwie ein paar Probleme gibt.
Das ist nicht unbedingt immer böse Absicht, sondern ist das einfach viel mehr?
Ja, genau, du hast halt da irgendwie 1100 Änderungsanträge, du bist noch mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt, und hast vielleicht deinen Urlaub schon im Hinterkopf. Du musst halt noch kurz diese Sitzung hinter dich bringen und verlässt dich, dass jemand anderes das genau nachgeschaut hat. Aber der Mitarbeiter hat vielleicht gerade Liebeskummer oder sonst irgendwie. In der Regel sind das ja so ganz komische...
Oder anders ausgedrückt, die da oben haben mal wieder was beschlossen, weil die da unten nicht in der Lage waren, denen mal zu sagen, wie der Hase läuft.
Das ist ein Ding so. Also im Endeffekt, es geht halt so weiter irgendwie. Wir werden halt eine Woche lang Lobbying machen. Da gibt es dann auch irgendwie noch Events mit Experten, die dann noch mal interessierten Mitarbeitern und Abgeordneten alles erklären, zusammen mit der Electronic Frontier Foundation und so organisiert. Dann ist halt Anfang September. Die Endabstimmung im EU-Parlament ist am 22. September. Die sollte eigentlich am 2. September sein, aber sie ist verschoben worden. Die haben ja auch nicht jede Woche Sitzungswoche. Die müssen ja immer zum Abstimmen nach Straßburg fahren usw. Also ist es schon mal verschoben worden, was erstmal ein gutes Zeichen ist. Diese Verschiebung zeigt, wir haben noch Verhandlungsbedarf und wir müssen da nochmal drüber nachdenken. Uns bringt das halt viel mehr Zeit, da nochmal reinzukrätschen und Leute zu mobilisieren. Bei uns sieht der Zeitplan so aus, wir machen der Lobbying, wir schauen, was geht. Es werden auch im Moment kollaborativ auf europäischer Ebene Endungsanträge, die in unserem Sinne sind. Also eine verbraucherschutz- und bürgerechtsfreundliche Änderungsanträge geschrieben, die man einfach den Abgeordneten anbietet. Das war auch ein Erfolg bei den Softwarepatenten. Dann sucht man sich halt genau die Musikabgeordneten, die bringen die einfach rein. Damals bei den Softwarepatenten sind wir in der Nacht vor den Abstimmungen von Tür zu Tür gelaufen, im EU-Parlament, wo wir uns aufgehalten haben und haben denen Abstimmungsabfehlungen hingelegt. Und da stand halt drauf, wenn sie im Sinne von uns den Digital Rights Gruppen abstimmen wollen, dann bei der ersten Sache, dann drücken sie C und am dritten drücken sie A und sonst irgendetwas. Und man nimmt ihnen einfach die Arbeit ab. Hier die Wahlmöglichkeit für ein freies Internet. Das ist halt der Plan.
Die Fernbedienung für den EU-Parlamentar.
Wir versuchen das halt in dieser Lobby-Woche da genug Leute zu mobilisieren. Da müssen wir auch noch schauen, wir brauchen halt noch aus östlichen Staaten Aktivisten.
Also ihr sucht noch Kräfte?
Wir suchen noch Kräfte, die in dieser Woche mit nach Brüssel kommen. Wir haben da so ein temporäres Hackerspace aufgebaut. Es ist im Endeffekt sinnvoller, wenn Pole zu den polnischen Abgeordneten läuft, als wenn ich dahin laufe. Wir brauchen natürlich auch immer, ein Erfolg von den Software-Patenten war auch damals beim Lobby, die langhaarigen haben wir zu den Linken geschickt und die Anzugträger zu den Konservativen. Und im Endeffekt ist das halt auch wiederum eine sinnvolle Strategie. Und im Optimalfall schickst du die langhaarigen Polen zu den polnischen Linken und die Polen im Anzug zu den polnischen Konservativen. Es gibt halt eine ganze Menge Staaten, die ich nicht abdecken kann, weil irgendwie, wenn es um Griechen über sowas zu unterhalten, wo wir beide irgendwie jetzt nicht perfekt das Englisch sprechen und wo es die ganze Zeit um Juradzeug gibt, nicht ganz so sinnvoll. Also das heißt nichts, aber sinnvoller wäre es, wenn Grieche dahin rennen.
Eigentlich wollte man so eine europäische Aktivisten-Jobbörse für solche Kurzeinsätze.
Ja genau, also unser Hauptproblem ist halt erstmal, also ich hoffe das klappt alles, dass irgendwie La Quartier du Net kümmert sich da gerade drum, dass erstmal Spenden eingesammelt werden von Organisationen und Spendern, die halt irgendwie ein Interesse daran haben an so einer sinnvollen Gesetzgebung. Dass wir halt erstmal überhaupt die paar, die erstmal Interesse gezeigt haben, das waren leider auch nicht so viele, also wir haben uns auch über unsere ganzen Kanäle irgendwie eine Mailing-Liste weiter geschickt, da haben sich so gut wie keiner dafür interessiert. Wie immer. Aber wenigstens aus Deutschland gab es jetzt gerade drei. Also alles von Netzpolitik-Autoren, wo wir gesagt haben, wir wollen dahin. Aber für uns ist ja erstmal die Basisfrage, wir brauchen eigentlich im Optimalfall, wir können Schlafsäcke und E-Säcke mitbringen, notfalls. Hotelzimmer wäre natürlich cooler, oder irgendwo eine Couch, aber notfalls bringen wir selbst was mit. Aber es wäre natürlich auch cooler, wenn wir schon in einem teuren Brüssel unser ganzes Essen selbst bezahlen, wenn uns jemand die Fahrt finanziert. Und das versucht gerade La Quatre à la Tour, die Netze zu organisieren. Das sieht auch ganz gut aus. Und es gibt Belgier, also die in Brüssel sitzen, die organisieren uns da gerade auch schon Räumlichkeiten so, dass wir halt da Internet haben und unsere Schlafsäcke irgendwie aufbauen können. Und dann geht es da halt eine Woche lang rum, irgendwie mit verschiedensten Leuten aus ganz Europa einfach zu schauen, wie können wir da mal eine Woche lang irgendwie das EU-Parlament hacken und mal schauen, kriegen wir da irgendwie genug Leute irgendwie davon überzeugt, dass ihre Kompromisslinie, wovon sie jetzt überzeugt sind, dass sie einen Kompromiss beschlossen haben, dass es im Interesse aller ist, dass das halt eine ganz schlechte Idee ist, weil das passt genau so schlecht, wie was sie vormalten. Und danach ist halt unser Plan, dann fängt wieder die Massenmobilisierung an. Also so ab Anfang, zwischen irgendwie dem 2. und dem 15. September, wenn halt abzusehen ist, okay, es hat jetzt nichts erreicht, wir haben da immer noch keine Mehrheiten, dann wollen wir tatsächlich wieder die Massen mobilisieren. In ganz Europa, dass die Leute anfangen, ihre Abgeordneten irgendwie zu kontaktieren auf den unterschiedlichsten Wegen, und das wir halt wieder irgendwie, ja, notfalls deren Kommunikationswege irgendwie durch massenhafte Mobilisierungen lahmlegen können. Und einfach erklären können, hey, die Internet oder sehr viele Internetnutzer haben ein Interesse an einem freien Internet und spielt damit jetzt nicht gleichfertig rum und entscheidet am 22. September für ein freies und offenes Internet, weil dann ist dieser Prozess immer noch nicht abgeschlossen und dann hat nur das EU-Parlament endlich ein Ergebnis. Und dieses Ergebnis muss dann noch zusammen mit dem EU-Rat, da sind all die ganzen Staaten wieder zusammen und verschicken dann immer ihren Vertreter, das war der berühmteste Beispiel aus der Software-Patentekampagne, wo der Fischereiausschuss dann irgendwie darüber abgestimmt hat, dann muss der EU-Rat wiederum, der gerade halt unter der Ratspräsidentschaft von Frankreich ist, die die größten Hardliners sind, so in die ganzen Fragen Internet-Sperrung, muss man einen gemeinsamen Standpunkt finden, dieser Kompromissteil. Der EU-Rat wird irgendwann im Oktober oder im November zusammentreten. Und da gibt es halt verschiedenste Verfahren auf europäischer Ebene. Also entweder man findet dann einen gemeinsamen Standpunkt oder das EU-Parlament hat dann nochmal eine Möglichkeit, irgendwie zu sagen, na gut, wir genähren uns jetzt doch ein bisschen an oder nicht. Aber im Endeffekt gewinnt dann eigentlich auch immer der Rat, es sei denn, das EU-Parlament legt totales Veto ein, aber das ist halt relativ ungewöhnlich. Das haben wir bei den Zwergverpatienten erreicht gehabt, aber es ist halt ein bisschen komplex, was dann kommt. Aber im Endeffekt brauchen wir im Optimalfall im EU-Parlament eine Mehrheit, die deutlich sagt, hey, wir haben da jetzt ein paar Sachen extra nicht abgestimmt, um halt ein Zeichen zu setzen, wir wollen ein offenes Internet erhalten in Europa, wir haben Verbraucherrechte gestärkt, um halt gegenüber dem EU-Rat, wo man absehen kann, dass halt unsere EU-Staaten, also unsere Bundesregierung, wird da sicherlich keine große verbraucherfreundliche, in den Urheberrechtsfragen vor allem, wo die ganzen Knackpunkte vor allen Dingen hängen, darüber eine verbraucherfreundliche Position vertreten. Also bei den Sachen wie Roaming und sonstige Sachen, da gibt es ja gar keine Diskussion, das finden ja alle toll, weil da macht man ja immer gute Stimmung bei den ganzen Bürgern, wenn man halt, wir retten euch jetzt vor dem Ausverkauf durch die Take-O's. Aber in diesen Urheberrechtsfragen, das tut halt mal wieder komplette Gesetzgebungsinternetze irgendwie betreffen.
Ihr fahrt nach Brüssel?
Genau.
Obwohl das Parlament sitzt ja in Straßburg, aber das sind gar keine Büros, oder wie?
Doch, das sind so Bienenwaben. Also, die ganzen Abgeordneten haben da so kleine, ganz kleine Büros und die fahren halt immer nur einmal im Monat für eine Woche nach Brüssel. Also da setzt sich so der ganze irgendwie im Treck aus Brüssel oder wo die halt gerade herkommen vom Wochenende ins Urlaub. Die Mitarbeiter wohnen ja in der Regel in Brüssel. Die setzen sich dann irgendwie montagsmorgens in den Zug, fahren nach Straßburg. Die ganzen Abgeordneten fliegen aus der ganzen EU ein, weil die fahren in der Regel immer nach Hause am Wochenende. Montags und mittags beginnt dann in Straßburg ein Abstimmungsmarathon und sonstwie. Es gibt auch Ausschüsse, Sitzungen und sonstwie. Die Abgeordneten haben so kleine Büros. In der Regel schleppen die auch immer nur ihre Büroleiter oder einen Mitarbeiter mit. Der Rest bleibt halt in Brüssel. Da haben sie halt größere Büros. Jeder Mitarbeiter hat in der Regel sein eigenes Büro.
Dann zum Wochenendausflug, wir stimmen jetzt mal ab.
Genau, und freitags fährt man wieder zurück. Und dann ist man wieder drei Wochen in Brüssel. Das ist also auch eine große Diskussion. Auf europäischer Ebene kann man sich das überhaupt leisten. Im Endeffekt war es auch mal wieder so ein typischer politischer Formelkompromiss. Kriegt Belgien das eine, kriegt Frankreich das andere. Und dann schreiten wir uns nicht mehr.
Ja, hm, wir haben jetzt schon angesprochen, was man alles so mit einbringen kann. Wir haben jetzt gehört, wir brauchen langhaarige und kurzhaarige Polen und Griechen in unterschiedlicher Kohleur. Wir brauchen auch Deutsche, auch mit allen Haarlängen.
Auch mit allen Haarlängen, die müssen nicht unbedingt vor Ort sein, aber die Deutschen sind das wichtigste Land in der EU. Wir stellen 99 Europa-Abgeordnete und das sind die meisten. Und wenn wir, und Österreicher auch und sonst irgendwie, wenn wir die Deutschen und Österreicher komplett auf unsere Linie hätten, dann wäre das ja schon fast alles gewonnen. Aber natürlich das Problem, da sind auch die ganzen Konservativen dabei, die sind normalerweise nie auf unserer Linie, aber Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel. Auch die kann man teilweise mit sinnvollen Argumenten und indem man ruhig ihnen was beschreibt, teilweise vom Gegenteil überzeugen. Die Liberalen sind immer relativ gespalten. Da gibt es die eine Fraktion, die sagt, Datenschutz ist wichtig, die andere sagen, Datenschutz ist toll, aber Urheberrechte sind wichtiger, dann ist der Datenschutz ausgesticht. Dann gibt es die Sozialdemokraten, die haben eigentlich auch immer sehr zwiespältig. Die einen stimmen für das, die anderen für das, aber die kann man eigentlich auch überzeugen. Bei Linken und Grünen muss man eigentlich auch drauf gehen, aber in der Regel sind die halt eher so, die haben jetzt keine großen Connections zur Musik- und Filmindustrie, um deren Sachen zu vertreten. Also die sind halt eher immer auf bürgerechtsfreundlich und datenschutzfreundlich eingestellt.
Was heißt denn, ihr geht eigentlich primär wirklich die Volksparteien an?
Genau, eigentlich die Volksparteien, um da irgendwie so Flöcke reinzuhauen und da einflussreiche Leute davon zu überzeugen. Da ist natürlich das Problem in der Regel, also eigentlich muss man halt versuchen, irgendwie diese Schattenberichterstatter oder tatsächlich die Berichterstatter zu bekommen. Aber die verlieren ja teilweise ihr Gesicht, wenn die erstmal im Kompromissvorschlag zustimmen und dann hinterher sagen, sie stimmen dann nicht mehr für, weil sie ja festgestellt haben, dass sie aber im ersten Mal nicht so genau Peil davon hatten. Aber eigentlich müssen sie die halt umdrehen. Weil das sind halt die Leute, die am meisten Einfluss wiederum ausüben auf alle anderen. Aber das sind auch die Schwierigsten. Aber man kann halt genauso gut zu dem Fischereipolitiker gehen und ihm klarmachen, hey, nächste Zeit sind Wahlen. Das funktioniert jetzt alles so und so. Du nimmst ja kurz eine Viertelstunde Zeit, ich erkläre dir mal, was die Situation ist und du hast auch eine Stimme und du musst nicht irgendwie mit deinem Schattenbrichtestatter übereinstimmen, sondern du kannst auch noch in unserer Votingliste irgendwie stimmen. Und deswegen hat jeder eigentlich die Möglichkeit, sich an seine Abgeordneten zu wenden. Und wir werden bis dahin halt diese Votinglisten fertig haben an Wahlempfehlungen. Wir werden bis dahin auch die komplette Dokumentation Anfang September haben, in einfacher Sprache auch, sodass jeder irgendwie diese Argumentation verstehen kann, Argumentationsleitfahnen zur Hand hat. Wir werden noch schauen, ob wir mehr Kampagnen, Werkzeuge bis dahin haben, die man einsetzen kann. Und dann kann man halt schauen, dass man einerseits mailt. Wobei mailen immer relativ problematisch ist.
Wenn die Mail-Nehmer ausgedruckt werden muss, bevor sie im Abgott kommen.
Nee, das nicht. Aber in der Regel haben die Outlook. Und da setzen sie in der Regel entweder sofort Spamfilter. Oder es wird sofort an jemand weitergeleitet, der der Experte dafür ist. Also Faxe sind eindeutig besser geeignet. Briefe sind sehr gut. Ähnlich wie Faxe. Die nimmt man haptisch in die Hand. Die muss man erstmal aufklappen und sonst irgendwie aus dem Plätzgerät rausnehmen, bevor man sie zusammenknüllen und wegschmeißen kann. Die kann man auch viel besser in einen Vorlagenordner einsortieren. Dass es dann vom Mitarbeiter zum Abgeordneten geht, weil die haben nur ihren Vorlagenordner. Anrufe sind auch ganz gut. Die Kombination ist natürlich immer prima. Haben Sie mein Fax gelesen, was ich Ihnen geschickt habe am Telefon? Da kann man auch verschiedene durchprobieren, verschiedene Abgeordnete. Man kann darüber bloggen und kommunizieren. Das ist immer sehr sinnvoll. Andere Leute darauf aufmerksam machen, dass es da was gibt, wo man sich engagieren sollte und dass es da leichte Anleitungen gibt, wie man das machen kann. Im Endeffekt, wenn man sich das durchgelesen hat und das teilweise sogar verfolgt. Wir versuchen, das so aufzubereiten, dass man auch in 5 oder 10 Minuten Zeit in der Mittagspause mal kurz anrufen kann und einfach mal nachfragen kann. Wenn das ganz viele Leute tun aus ganz Europa, dann hat man ja schon eine ganze Menge gemacht. Es gibt ein paar Grundregeln, die sollte man beachten. Höflich bleiben. Es mag ja auch kein Mensch, wenn ein anderer Mensch, den man noch nicht mal kennt, einen blöd anmacht. Auch wenn man das Gefühl hat, die Politiker bauen eine ganze Menge Scheiße, man weiß nie, ob gerade auch der Mitarbeiter oder der Abgeordnete am Telefon, manchmal gehen tatsächlich auch die Abgeordneten ran, wenn man da anruft, ob das jetzt ein guter oder ein böser ist. Auf jeden Fall, selbst wenn es ein böser ist, dann möchte man ihn ja trotzdem davon überzeugen, dass er vielleicht irgendwie aus Unkenntnis handelt.
Also mit Beschimpfen kann man keine Abstimmung gewinnen.
Genau, das bringt halt überhaupt nichts. Da kann man auch gleich irgendwie, im wahrsten Sinne, wie es ja immer geschrieben wird, ich kotze mich jetzt in meinem Blog voll aus oder so das machen. Oder Heiseforum. Genau, Heiseforum, die haben da gute Tierhüter. Aber im Endeffekt, das bringt halt nichts. Also höflich bleiben, argumentieren. Dann, was natürlich auch immer so irgendwie unter Nerds sehr beliebt ist, Voll labern. Das ist auch nicht unbedingt jedes Mal die richtige Strategie. Also, wenn man dem anderen gar keine Chance lässt, ihn nachfragen zu stellen, dann hat er gegenüber in vielen Fällen schon nach dem dritten Satz irgendwie abgeschaltet, weil er überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, worum es überhaupt geht. Also, das sind halt die sehr übereifrigen und sonst irgendwie. Das hatten wir auch. Das war eine Patente Debatte, da hatten wir auch Leute dabei. Dann gingen wir in den Abgeordnetenbüro rein und die fingen an zu labern. Und man dachte, okay, jetzt kann man gleich wieder rausgehen. Aber na gut, sie waren halt motiviert und dabei. Aber im Endeffekt ist es halt argumentieren, höflich bleiben. Man muss ja auch im optimalen Fall immer anders argumentieren. Also, wenn ich einen Linken anrufe oder einen Grünen oder sonstigen, dann muss ich im optimalen Fall ein bisschen andere Vokabeln benutzen, eine leicht andere Argumentation, als wenn ich jetzt irgendwie einen CDUler anrufe. Aber der SPD ist immer ein bisschen schwieriger, weil man weiß dann nie, ob das die Linken oder die Rechten SPDler sind. CDU ist halt immer so Innovation und Arbeitsplätze und sonstige Sachen. Da kommt man halt mit der Verbraucherschutz-Argumentation meistens nicht so weit, aber Ausnahmen bestätigen da auch wieder die Regel. Also wenn jemand tatsächlich irgendwie von der CDU im Verbraucherschutz sitzt, kann man natürlich auch Verbraucher.
Gibt es denn Argumentationshilfen? Ich könnte mir eher vorstellen, dass so, wenn es jetzt so ein Wiki zu dem Thema gäbe, vielleicht gibt es ja sogar schon eins.
Also wir bauen jetzt gerade einen Netzpolitik-Wiki auf, da werden wir das Ganze machen. Die Franzosen machen das bei sich schon, aber wir dachten, es ist halt besser, wenn wir das alles in deutscher Sprache machen.
Genau, wenn man nachher wirklich so, was könnte man antworten auf folgende Fragen, die man beobachtet bekommt?
Es läuft noch nicht so wirklich schnell, das müssen wir noch ein bisschen optimieren, aber netzpolitik.org/wikiwerdenwir das Ganze zusammen aggregieren. Im Moment läuft immer das Debugging, was die halt tatsächlich da beschlossen haben, den Kompromissanträgen, weil das dauert ja eine Zeit lang, bis es halt raus ist irgendwie, vor allen Dingen weil die Sommerpause haben, was haben die da aus den 1100 Änderungsanträgen überhaupt abgestimmt, und dann muss man das puzzleartig zusammensetzen, und das kommt leider nicht so schnell, die ganzen Informationen kommen nicht so schnell bei uns an, weil die Politiker es teilweise selbst noch nicht wissen. Also da dieses Debugging läuft noch.
Debugging ist jetzt aus den Protokollen oder was?
Jaja, und um halt zu sehen, da manchmal sind es ja auch mündliche Kompromisssachen in dieser Sitzung, da muss man die Protokolle abwarten und sonst irgendwie, da muss man auch nochmal, das sind ja Prozesse, die dauern ja viel länger, vor allen Dingen wenn alle schon halb im Sommer sind.
Und wer macht dieses Debugging, ist das auch etwas, was man so mit Wikis oder ähnlichen Systemen in die Breite ziehen könnte?
Ja, aber das sind dann eher...
Oder eine parallele Recherche macht?
Das wird auch transparent dargestellt, was läuft dann erstmal irgendwie bei denjenigen, die am meisten Peil von haben von irgendwie Jura, europäischer Gesetzgebung, richtige Sprache, also da fühle ich mich auch teilweise ein bisschen in bestimmten Fällen überfordert, das lasse ich halt lieber denjenigen, die da die Experten sind.
Ja klar, aber ich meine auch vielleicht kann man das halt so crowdsourcen, ich meine Millionen Computer suchen nach externen Leben, so auf Basis der Analyse von Weltraumstrahlung, da könnte man ja auch diese EU-Parlamentsstrahlung mal...
Das machen wir auch, also das auf Englischer oder Sprache, das ist halt ein bisschen bei La Quadrature du nett im Wiki, aber wir haben da immer noch nicht alle Ergebnisse zusammen, wir kriegen die ja auch teilweise irgendwie, also die stehen ja noch nicht wirklich alle öffentlich, sondern wir kriegen das durch irgendwie uns nahestehende oder mit uns sympathisierenden Abgeordneten, Mitarbeiter oder sonst irgendwie zugeschickt und da muss man halt auch erstmal warten, bis sie halt online stehen, um das nochmal zu verifizieren, darauf zu verlinken und sonst irgendwie und da, dieser Prozess, da werden wir eigentlich schon, lieben gern, viel weiter, weil in zwei Wochen wollen wir eigentlich schon unsere ganzen, wenn wir in Brüssel sind, unsere ganzen irgendwie Empfehlungen haben. Bis dahin wird es auch fertig sein, aber bis eben, als ich letztes Mal online war, war es noch nicht fertig. Und deswegen, wir warten, aber die werden halt online stehen und dann gibt es auch immer irgendwie, es gibt eine Menge Mailing-Listen, wo man sich irgendwie eintragen kann, damit diskutieren kann, und vor allen Dingen über Blogs.
Aber jetzt verstehe ich auch deinen ursprünglichen Wunsch, also den du eingangs formuliert hast, so, es müssten mehr Leute sich sozusagen auch konkret mit dem Herausziehen dieser Informationen beschäftigen, einfach um auch verwertbares Material überhaupt erst zu generieren für neue Kampagnen, um überhaupt auch richtig argumentieren zu können. Ja, das ist wichtig. Ja, das heißt, das geschieht jetzt alles bald. Dann hoffe ich, dass das auch mal Folgen zeigen wird. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt recht zuversichtlich in gewisser Hinsicht, also was so die Aktivität als solche betrifft, weil man hat ja schon auch Vorteile, wenn man aus dem Internet und aus der breiten Masse heraus die Sachen angeht als neue Gegenkraft zu den etablierten Lobby-Organisationen. Was ist so deine Erfahrung, wie die Wahrnehmung ist in der Politik, so das Internet in seiner Breite mit diesen Massenkampagnen versus die Lobby-Garde?
Unser größter Erfolg in der Kampagne gegen Softwarepatente war, dass da auf einmal Menschen wie du und ich im Europaparlament vor deren Büros standen und meinten, ihr redet hier gerade über unsere Arbeitsplätze. Ich bin jetzt extra aus dem tiefsten Polen angereist, um euch zu erklären, dass das keine gute Idee ist. Am nächsten Tag stand der teuer bezahlte Lobbyist von Microsoft vor der Tür und war nicht mehr so glaubwürdig, wie er vorher war. Man hat Vorteile in Sachen Glaubwürdigkeit. Politiker sind ja nicht die Bösen, die da alles schlecht machen. Die sind in der Regel nur wegen zu großer Komplexität manchmal überfordert. Die sind ganz froh, wenn da auch mal andere Leute vorbeikommen, wenn da halt echt mal richtige Bürger vorbeikommen. Die ganzen Soldner, die für die Lobby und PR-Agenturen nur Soldnertum spielen und für teures Geld Astro-Turfing und sonstige. Wir schieben euch jetzt mal unsere Interessen drunter. Das sind ja auch in der Regel viele nette Leute, die leider sowas machen, aber es sind ja sehr viele, die schleimigen, schmierigen Anzugträger, mit denen man nicht gerne abends ein Bier trinken gehen möchte. Damit sind die Politiker konfrontiert und die Mitarbeiter. Die Menschen haben eine höhere Glaubwürdigkeit, wenn man es so gut vermittelt, wenn man argumentativ und höflich auftritt. Weil wir leben in einer Demokratie, da hat jeder das Recht, sich einzumischen. Als ich anfing mit Netzpolitik, das war vor zehn Jahren, da gab es die üblichen paar Verdächtigen, die so etwas machten. In den letzten zehn Jahren ist, wenn man von der Bewegung reden möchte, es massiv gewachsen. Also sehr viel mehr Menschen sind sich dieses Thema bewusst, sind sich dieser komplexen Fragestellungen oder sind sich darüber bewusst, dass jetzt die Rahmenbedingungen einer digitalen Gesellschaft gestellt werden. Sie haben eine Awareness und sie wollen sich auch einsetzen. Also man kann Massen mobilisieren. Wenn wir jetzt hier von Massen reden, dann reden wir von 15.000 Leuten, die auf eine Demo gehen und 35.000 Leute, die sonst was machen. Es sind immer noch nicht die Millionen, die da rausgehen. Aber das ist ja schon mal durch das Internet vernetzt, sind das irgendwie sehr starke...
Man könnte auf jeden Fall schon mal mit der Hörerschaft von Chaosradio Express anfangen. Da hätte man schon eine ganz ordentliche Demo beisammen.
Ja, nicht nur eine Demo, aber wenn nur jeder zweite Zuhörer tatsächlich mit einem Abgeordneten Kontakt aufnimmt, dann, hey, das ist massive Kampagnenleistungen, das ist eine massive... Allein mal muss ich dir mal vorstellen, was die Hälfte der Hörer für Kommunikationswege blockieren können. Also früher hat man sich einfach...
Indem die Faxe da raus...
Zum Beispiel das. Aber früher hat man sich irgendwie in der Kälte vor das Atomkraftwerk gesetzt. Und wir können halt Kommunikationswege blockieren und darüber noch irgendwie unsere Argumentation rüberbringen.
Na, dann werden wir das wohl auch jetzt mal alle tun. Ich kann nur alle dazu auffordern, sich hier auch zu engagieren. Ich denke, wir haben jetzt das Thema auch ausreichend gecovert. Hast du noch ein letztes Wort, Markus?
Weiß ich jetzt auch. Das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen zu plötzlich, aber...
Ist jetzt zu plötzlich. Wolltest du noch einen Aspekt bringen?
Also natürlich konnte ich jetzt noch 1000 Aspekte bringen. Ja, aber im Endeffekt ist es unsere digitale Gesellschaft oder unsere, wie man es auch die einen nennt, Informations-Gesellschaft oder Informations-Gesellschaft oder sonst irgendwie, es ist unsere Demokratie. Demokratie lebt von Teilhabe und Demokratie lebt davon, dass sich jeder einzelne einmischt. Und wir haben die Tools, es ist einfacher als früher, sich einzumischen und es ist auch viel besser, wenn man sich irgendwie einmischen, wenn es nur irgendwie kurzzeitiger Aktivismus oder sonst irgendwie ist, als wenn man sich einfach nur hinstellt und die ganze Zeit sagt, die da oben sind blöd, die bauen nur irgendeinen Scheiß und selbst überhaupt nicht den Arsch hoch bekommt, weil dann überlässt man echt die Demokratie all den Leuten, denen man sie überhaupt nicht gönnt, aus gutem Recht. Dann überlässt man sie halt den ganzen Lobbyisten, die da hinrennen und gegen uns irgendwie Gesetze durchbringen. Dann überlässt man sie den Sicherheitspolitikern, die halt ihre eigene Agenda und so weiter haben. Und das ist unsere Demokratie und wir müssen die uns einfach irgendwie zurückgewinnen.
Also ich schließe mich dem an, das ist absolut richtig. Ich denke auch, dass mehr bewegt werden kann, als man manchmal glaubt. Lange Zeit haben wir so immer dieses Ideal gesucht, so das Internet, das kann uns irgendwie zusammenbringen und so weiter. Und Tatsache ist, so weit sind wir jetzt. Jetzt kann man das tatsächlich zum Laufen bringen. Die Softwarepatientekampagne hat das gezeigt, die Vorwärtsdatenspeicherungskampagne hat gezeigt, hier wird es sicherlich auch etwas bewirken. Und da ist auch noch so recht kein Ende in Sicht. Schon beim letzten Mal, als wir hier über Politik geredet haben, mit Falk kam halt auch so dieses Thema auf, mit Bautools, Bautwerkzeuge, so mehr jetzt nur, als ich schreibe mal was in meinem abgeordneten Brief im Internet, sondern ich denke, dass da einfach eine ganze Menge Systeme gebaut werden können, die einfach auch konkreten Nutzen haben. Wie zum Beispiel Recherche-Hilfen, Auszüge herausziehen aus dem politischen Prozess, in dem man Protokolle auswertet, was ich indiziere, zusammenstellt, verlinkt, you name it. Und da ist die Kreativität gefragt, auch der Programmierer, aber auch der Nicht-Programmierer. Und ich denke, die Kampagne kann unter Umständen auch noch ein gutes Logo und ein schickes T-Shirt gebrauchen, zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Wir brauchen Banner, wir brauchen eigentlich alles.
Aber es ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, jetzt hier bei der aktuellen Nachrichtenlage das Ganze auch wirklich jetzt auf so griffige Formeln runterzubrechen. Da muss sicherlich noch ein bisschen drauf gearbeitet werden. Aber das ist dann nachzulesen bei nutzpolitik.org. Vielleicht dann auch bald im Wiki. Wann soll das kommen?
Ja, es ist eigentlich schon da. Wir müssen das noch ein bisschen beschleunigen.
Wenn es fertig ist.
Genau. Also bis Ende August werden wir das alles drin haben. Spätestens, wenn wir halt in Brüssel sind und dann mit den anderen irgendwie da die ganze Kampagne im Endeffekt durchgeplant haben.
Gut, kommt alles. Jetzt machen wir aber hier einen Punkt. Ich denke, wir haben das alles ganz gut zusammengefasst. Ja, ich bedanke mich mal wieder fürs Zuhören. Ich bedanke mich bei dir, Markus, für die Ausführung. Und das war's. Chaosradio Express, Nummer 95. Noch mal schnell zwischengeschoben vor der nächsten Livesendung am Sonntag. Die letzte auf Funkwelle und dann geht's aber hier auch wieder weiter mit vielen tausend Themen, wie ihr es gewohnt seid und wie ihr es gerne möchtet. Ich bedanke mich noch mal und sage tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.